[Music]
The Bilderberg
group,
Atlantis, Serpent
DNA. Does the Vatican control the
Freemasons? Or do the Freemasons control
the
[Music]
Vatican? These people are sick.
It's a big club and you ain't in
it. Symbolism will be their
[Music]
[Applause]
downfall. So, I'm somewhat interested in
conspiracy theories. I don't believe in
them, but it's one of those things, you
know, like cults or serial killers. I
don't want to join a cult. I don't want
to kill anybody, but when it happens, I
take an interest. Ooh, what's going on
here? It's good to start a video by
saying something nice. So, let's all go
around and say our favorite thing about
conspiracy theorists. I'll go first. My
favorite thing about conspiracy
theorists is their passion for diagrams.
As long as the internet has existed,
researchers have posted conspiracy
[Music]
diagrams. This is one from 1999 with
Lucifer at the top. Before the internet,
people had to draw these things by hand.
The pyramid shape is considered
traditional. I remember seeing this one
around 2010. At the bottom are the debt
slaves, the sheeple. You are here above
us. World population control, religion,
government, education, media, and then
like corporations, man. Then the banks,
the think tanks, the elite families, the
crown, and at the very top, the
allseeing eye. Maybe it's the
Illuminati. Maybe it's the reptiles.
Maybe it's daddy when he's arrived and
he's taking his belt off. You know, it's
like daddy arrived and he's taking his
belt off. Let's face it, most conspiracy
diagrams look like the untethered
scribblings of incurable screw balls.
And maybe they are, but I think they're
also a sincere attempt to understand the
shape of power. Not a good attempt, but
that's okay. I no longer expect good
things. Every conspiracy diagram is an
answer to the question, who really
controls the world? The pyramid
represents hierarchy. It's like those
medieval drawings of the great chain of
being. Medieval Europeans saw reality
itself as a kind of pyramid with God at
the top, the supreme being. Each tier
beneath him represents a lower
emanation. The orders of angels, humans,
animals, plants, and minerals. Medieval
cosmology was a mirror of medieval
politics. As below, so above. The feudal
system was a pyramid with the monarch at
the top, then nobles, knights, vassels,
merchants, peasants, and surfs. In 2023,
passionate graphic designer Dylan Lewis
Monroe created a conspiracy diagram
called the world hierarchy pyramid. It
combines the medieval great chain of
being with every conspiracy theory. At
the top is the tetrogrammaton. That's
the Hebrew name of God. Then the angels,
the extraterrestrials, dark AI,
transdimensional ETS, the Borg,
Anunnaki, Draco reptilians, Satan,
source. Second Corinthians. do your own
research. Then of course the elite
bloodlines, the secret societies, of
course. Of course, and way down at the
bottom, the matrix. 9 to5 dead slaves,
peasants, sheep, cattle, NPCs, maskers,
monster energy drinks. Oh, they think
it's satanic. So, you go into
Hebrew. The letter V is also the number
six. You could have here in Hebrew 666
on the can. Now, do you know what a mil
is?
I
do. Breeders. Hey, don't talk that way
about straight people. One of my best
friends happens to be Wait a minute.
Does that say
[Music]
goyam? Okay, it is way too early in the
video for this. I'm trying to keep it
fun, trying to keep it flirty. We are
not dealing with Goyam for at least an
hour. So, put a pin in it. And for now,
I'll pretend I didn't see that. The
world hierarchy pyramid looks like
something you'd find in the basement of
a domestic terrorist.
[Music]
Some,
how can someone be this wrong about
every aspect of reality? Is anything
about this right? Well, isn't it true
that power is a pyramid? You could make
a less crazy pyramid diagram. a 1911
illustration called the pyramid of the
capitalist system. Oh god, we're already
talking about capitalism never beating
the bread tube allegations. The pyramid
of the capitalist system has the workers
at the bottom, then the bourgeoisi, the
army, clergy, politicians, and at the
very top in place of the king in place
of God is money itself. A conspiracy
theorist would look at this and say,
"Well, that can't be right. Money can't
be at the top because money does not
conspire. Money has no plans, no
intentions of its own. It isn't good or
evil. It just is. So, who controls the
money? Who really controls the
world? What's up, you guys? Just checked
into the Watergate
Hotel. No need to break in. That's
cute. Nice
view. Not very private, honestly. Not a
great place to do a
conspiracy. Part one, just asking
[Music]
questions. So, I spent the last year of
my life researching conspiracy theories
online and I'm not doing well. Every
time you saw Taylor Swift on your TV at
the Super Bowl, you were flashed with
demonic hand gestures and an inverted
cross. Did he just say Taylor swifed? I
can't even tell reality from parody
anymore. It's like that essay, A modest
proposal by Jonathan Swift. I feel like
I'm losing my mind. So, to ground
myself, I tried asking some normal,
non-terminally online people what they
think about conspiracy theories. And
what I found is that for most people,
conspiracy theories are a mainly
harmless game they play. The game of
what if. You know, what if Tupac and
Elvis are still alive? And what if they
hang out in the UFO at Area 51 with
Sasquatch and Taylor Swift's gay whiff?
Sure, why not? Speculating about who
really killed JFK is basically America's
pastime? Because it's more exciting than
baseball and it's like a murder mystery.
We all get to play detective. Was it the
Russians, the CIA, pro-Castro Cubans,
anti-Castro Cubans, Colonel Mustard on
the grassy null with the magic bullet?
America has a weird obsession with JFK.
I feel like it's because of two things.
One, he's hot. Two, he's dead. And it's
that combination of hot and dead that
really gets our juices flowing. Whenever
I imagine JFK, I see him silhouetted
against soft white light, and he smiles
at me lovingly in slow motion. JFK is
America's beautiful dead wife in a
flashback. He's our dead anime mom.
Okasan, I can't believe we fumbled her.
So, look, I hate to be a buzzkill. I
know it's fun to speculate wildly about
the secret conspiracies behind world
events, but for me, it stopped being fun
a long time ago. I can't pinpoint when
exactly, but there's a couple moments
that stand out. Exhibit A is Edgar
Madison Welch, who on December 4, 2016
drove from North Carolina to Washington
DC and entered neighborhood pizzeria
comet pingpong with an AR-15 rifle,
which he fired through a closet door,
terrifying customers and staff. He later
told police he was quote
self-investigating. He was doing his own
research. He was self-investigating the
Pizzagate conspiracy theory, which
falsely claimed that leaked emails from
my close personal friend Hillary Clinton
contained cryptic references to an elite
underground satanic ritual murder and
child sex trafficking operation. It's a
shame because baseless speculation about
the lurid sexual depravity of the rich
and famous can be a lot of fun, but when
someone picks up a gun, the truth is not
a game. The shooter would later tell the
New York Times, quote, "The intel on
this wasn't
100%." Yeah. Exhibit B is America's
foremost conspiracy theorist for the
last quarter century, Alex Jones, live
on Infowars, mogging the father of a
child who was killed at Sandy Hook. And
I know Alex Jones has paid a heavy price
for this, but it is pretty heinous. I I
mean, it's like, yeah. Oh, read this
card.
Okay. I mean, it's like, whoa.
Wa. I don't know. Is this what
questioning authority looks like? It's
not just asking questions if the way
you're going about it is uh fish. Of
course, when you point out the harm done
by conspiracy theorists, they say,
"Well, that's just controlled
opposition. It's a scop designed to make
us look bad." And okay, I guess it's
possible that it's a scop. But isn't it
also possible that you've simply
surrounded yourself with [ __ ]
Conspiracy theorists tend not to take
criticism well. They feel like you're
manipulating them, like you're shaming
and vilifying people just for
questioning official narratives. And
isn't that exactly what they'd expect a
shill for the deep state to do? Isn't
conspiracy theorists just a slur for
anyone who dares to snap out of their
programming? A convenient way to silence
anyone who questions the establishment?
Well, it's good to be skeptical and it's
good to ask questions, but there's a
difference between intelligent
skepticism and, for example, denying
well-documented events on the basis of
wild conjecture posted online by some
maniac moments before harpooning his own
parents. Just because you're asking
questions doesn't mean the questions
you're asking are
good. Who really controls the
moon? No one controls the moon, Vanessa.
That's not a good question. Go back to
your desk. Conspiracy theorists think of
themselves as speaking truth to power
and challenging the establishment. But
is that even what they're doing? See, I
can also ask questions. My first
question is, which establishment are you
questioning? Does this establishment
include Donald Trump and Elon Musk? I
noticed Alex Jones and many other
conspiracy theorists have taken to
shilling for both of them now that they
are collaborating so closely,
conspiring, if you will. One thing we've
seen in the United States over the last
decade is that when an entire political
party embraces conspiracy theories, you
can't really say that conspiracy
theorists are questioning propaganda
because the conspiracy theories are the
propaganda. On December 2nd, 2015,
presidential contender Donald Trump
appeared as a guest on Infowars with
Alex Jones. Let's look at the comments.
This video is shadowbanned. The elite
don't want the people to see this.
1984 is here. Okay. But the interview is
on YouTube and it was the first result
when I Googled it and Donald Trump is
the president of the most powerful
country in the world. So, who exactly
are the elite? Isn't what people call
the elite or the establishment really
just a bunch of waring factions? And
isn't one of those factions the United
States Republican Party, now essentially
a right-wing conspiracist party, their
three-time presidential nominee and
two-term president, two-term president
so far, entered politics in 2011 as a
birther conspiracy theorist. But he was
just asking questions, right?
[Applause]
step
back. MPD, stand back up to the deck. On
January 6th, 2021, the capital was
stormed by 10,000 self-described
patriots, aiming to violently overturn
the results of the 2020 election because
of conspiracy theories spread by Trump
and that scummy lawyer he used to hang
out with. Let's have trial by combat. We
will never give up. We will never
concede. We will stop the steel.
A month earlier, Trump's former national
security adviser, Michael Flynn, invoked
the stop the steel conspiracy theory in
a call for Trump to suspend the
Constitution and declare martial law.
Exactly the things conspiracy theorists
have been worried about for decades. But
when it actually happened in front of
their eyes, they didn't notice because
the conspiracy theory was the
propaganda. And in the background of all
this, of course, was KQAnon. I assume
you all know what KQanon is, but
sometimes it's good to verbalize it just
to remind yourself how much the vibes
have deteriorated. Q Anon was an online
messianic conspiracy cult whose core
belief was that the world is ruled by a
global elite of satanic sex trafficking
cannibals from whom the children would
be saved by reality TV star turned
President Donald Trump whose sacred
mission was to declare martial law, end
the adrenochrome harvest, and purge the
deep state ped cabal in a wave of mass
executions called the storm. This he
would accomplish with the help of
military intelligence insiders known as
Q, who only communicated with the public
via cryptic messages on a CD racist
image board called Aidcoon, operated by
a father-son team of American
pornographers out of a hog farm in the
Philippines. The online conspiracy world
has since moved on from QAnon. In fact,
they'll tell you that it was actually
controlled opposition and a
distraction. Denial is always the last
stage of these things. The so-called
QAnon shaman, Jacob Chanley, now claims
he was unfairly associated with QAnon by
the media in quote, an attempt to
control the narrative and destroy my
public image. It's not what he said four
years ago. Q most certainly did send me,
ladies and gentlemen. Q is the highest
levels of the military and the
intelligence community in the United
States and they are disseminating above
top secret information to patriots in
our republic. That means people like you
so that we can take back our country
from the communists and the globalists.
He now blames the whole thing on Antifa,
Black Lives Matter, and the deep state.
And I think it's more like uh the deep
state setup riots than Trump riots. I
don't think Trump had people do that. I
think it was more likely that the feds
and the crowd and anti and BLM were
largely responsible. It's like the
narcissist's prayer. You know, that
didn't happen. And if it did, it wasn't
that bad. And if it was, it was Nancy
Pelosy's fault. And if it wasn't, the
deep state made me do it. It was
controlled opposition that I was a part
of somehow. So, no, I'm not just going
to pretend QAnon didn't happen because
it would be convenient for you. If you
just memoryhole these things, then you
never learn anything and we just do it
all again. American politics is post
QAnon in the sense of like post 911 or
postapocalypse. It's not like things are
going back to the way they were and more
like this is just the way things are
now. QAnon's core idea was that the
world is ruled by a satanic pedophile
elite who must be purged by a right-wing
authoritarian takeover. And this idea is
as popular as ever. Here's right-wing
misogyny influencer and alleged sex
trafficker Andrew Tate, I don't even
want to be alive anymore, getting
131,000 likes on Elon's X.com for
announcing that drag queens at the 2024
Paris Olympic opening ceremony proved
that a satanic cabal controls the West.
Here's ambient enthusiast Roseanne Bar
on stage with Tucker Carlson in
September 2024, shrieking about cannibal
vampires and riing up the crowd for
another insurrection. You know, they eat
babies. That is not [ __ ] It's true.
So, it's not just the dogs and the cats,
not just the pets. They're full on
vampires. They love the taste of human
flesh and they drink human blood. Fouchi
gave everybody AIDS, too. Did you know
that? He did. Google it. These are not
fringe ideas anymore. Alex Jones has
faded from relevance, less because of
his deplatforming and more because of
the mainstreaming of his own ideas. He
used to be king of the fringe, but now
he's not so far from the center. A
little fish in a big conspiracist pond.
It would be an exaggeration to say that
conspiracy theories have become the
dominant form of political discourse,
but not that much of an exaggeration.
During the 2024 election season, four of
the top six podcasters on Spotify were
conspiracy theorists. President Trump's
campaign was backed by Elon Musk, who
tweeted about Pizzagate on the eve of
the election, the result of which
increased his net worth by $200 billion.
And Musk, of course, has now been
appointed to the newly created
Department of Government Efficiency or
Doge. Wealth, my lord, you win. T
interwebs today, good sir. Wait a
liberals epic style. Shadlay my brothers
top cat legalize comedy. I'm this close
to losing it. Don't [ __ ] with me fellas.
Another conspiracist Trump appointment
is RFK Jr. Did you just nominate the
time cube guy? Why not? It rotates in
four different directions simultaneously
toward midday, midnight, sun, sunown. It
rotates those directions simultaneously.
RFK Jr. who believes in chemtrails but
not vaccines, who claims CO 19 was
ethnically targeted to spare Jews and
the Chinese, who denies that AIDS is
caused by HIV, who's promised that he
quote won't take sides on 9/11.
He
forgot. So, conspiracy theories are no
longer for freaks and tinfoil hats
making public access TV shows about
Sasquatch. If that's all it was, I
wouldn't care. It's not my business what
you people do with Sasquatch in the
privacy of your own bedroom. But now
conspiracy theories are for the freaks
who run the country. And when it comes
to deciding, you know, which elections
are rigged or which mass tragedies are
hoaxes or which reptilians control the
central banks, it kind of becomes
everyone's business. Because for
democracy to work, you know, if that's
still a thing by the time this video
comes out, we the people need to have
reasonable conversations with each
other. And it's very hard to have
reasonable conversations with people who
think the World Health Organization is
controlled by highlevel luciferian
druids. So in this video, I just want to
ask some questions not about any
particular conspiracy theory, but about
conspiracism as a way of thinking. Why
do so many people believe in conspiracy
theories? Why are they so obsessed with
symbols and rituals? Why are they taking
over politics? Has this happened before?
When did this start? Is the internet to
blame? A funny thing about conspiracy
theories is no matter how wrong they
are, engaging with them forces you to
ask deep questions. Because there really
is something mysterious about truth and
power. How do we know what's true? What
authorities can we trust? Why do bad
things happen? Why are there wars? Why
is there poverty? Who really controls
the world? In this video, I will answer
all of these questions and more. So,
buckle your seat belt, Kansas. We're
going to take the rabbit pill and find
out just how deep Dorothy's hole goes.
[Music]
Part two, the rabbit
pill. Hello, Earthlings. Hope you're
having a good trip. Let's start by
looking at how conspiracy theorists
argue. I need to teach you to counter
those arguments so you can properly
shill for the Galactic Empire. A common
argument goes like this. Aren't there
endless examples of real conspiracies?
Everyone always thinks conspiracy
theories are crazy until those theories
are proven to be conspiracy fact. As a
Trump supporter on Truth Social put it,
"Not trusting the government doesn't
make you a conspiracy theorist. It makes
you a history buff." So, on the one
hand, yes, the government has done
things that are bad. They've even
deliberately done bad things in secret,
which might be the definition of a
conspiracy. And that's true of whatever
country you live in, but I'm going to
focus on the US because the Saturnian
order has commanded me to make America
look bad. Easiest job they've ever given
me. To choose a popular example, Project
MK Ultra was a wildly unethical CIA mind
control experiment carried out in secret
between 1953 and 1973. One of its goals
was to develop a truth serum using
substances like LSD and morphine. Now,
obviously, this did not work because
morphine and LSD are terrible truth
serums. Trust me, I've tried. We know
about MK Ultra because after the
Watergate scandal, Congress investigated
intelligence agency abuses and uncovered
CIA documents that were supposed to have
been destroyed. The details are very
scandalous. In an operation known as
Midnight Climax, the CIA lured men into
San Francisco, dosed them unknowingly
with LSD, and observed their behavior
through a one-way mirror. In another
experiment, US Army biologist Frank
Olsen was given LSD without his
knowledge or consent, and he died one
week later after falling from a
13thstory hotel window under suspicious
circumstances. It's true that there's no
shortage of real conspiracies. I'll put
some on the screen right now and you can
do your own research. So, you can't
really blame people for wondering if
this is the stuff that's declassified,
what else are they doing that we don't
know about? Probably a bunch of messed
up stuff. I'm not going to disagree with
you there. And many conspiracy theories
do have some kind of resemblance to
things that actually happened.
Antivaccination conspiracy theories are
almost entirely baseless. But in 2011,
the CIA located Osama bin Laden in
Pakistan by secretly collecting blood
samples under the pretext of a fake
vaccination program. QAnon is total
madness. But when high-profile men like
Epstein or Diddy are outed as prolific
sex criminals, it's not unreasonable to
wonder how many other rich and famous
people are complicit in those crimes.
So, with so much evidence of real
conspiracies, why shouldn't we take the
rabbit pill and go down Dorothy's hole?
Well, in short, because conspiracy
theories have less in common with real
conspiracies than might initially seem
to be the case. Conspiracists will tell
you that the term conspiracy theory was
invented by the CIA to discredit anyone
who questions official narratives. Uh,
this is not true. Quote, recorded use of
the phrase conspiracy theory dates back
to at least 1863, more than 60 years
before the CIA was established. That's
according to the Associated Press, but I
guess that's the mainstream media and we
can't trust them. I only trust truth
seekers posting about medbeds from a
garage and telling me to buy
cryptocurrency. When the quantum
financial system hits and I finally get
my Nasara Gasara deposit, you'll see.
You'll all see the difference between
actual conspiracies and conspiracy
theories has to do with evidence. When
we talk about conspiracy theories, we're
not talking about scientific theories
like the theory of gravity, which is a
wellsubstantiated hypothesis. At least
for you people, it's actually completely
false. But they won't let me talk about
that. We're using the word theory in the
non-scientific sense of unsubstantiated
conjecture and speculation. Just a
theory, as in the theory that Katy Perry
is John Bené Ramsay or that Jeffrey
Epstein is a 300-year-old vampire who
used to be Andrew Jackson. Conspiracy
theories are by definition
unsubstantiated in the way that UFOs are
by definition unidentified. If you know
what the object is, then it's not an
unidentified flying object. If credible
sources confirm a conspiracy occurred,
then it's not a conspiracy theory. And
to conspiracy theorists, a confirmed
conspiracy becomes part of the official
narrative, part of the puppet show, and
is therefore itself something to be
questioned. You see this all the time
with MK Ultra, where the actual
documented events only interest
conspiracy theorists in so far as they
inspire unsubstantiated speculation that
what we know is just the tip of the
iceberg. So conspiracy theories are to
investigative journalism as
cryptozoolology is to zoology. Zoology,
the study of animals, is a scientific
endeavor based on standards of evidence.
Cryptozoolology, the search for
Bigfoots, yetis, various mothmen, is a
crock-pot monster hunting activity based
on a parascientific pursuit of mystery
for the sake of mystery. Not to be too
harsh on cryptozoolology. I'd rather
people hunt Mothmen than do KQAnon. If
you're torn between the two, I want you
to promise me that you will not rest
until you have that moth man's head.
Cryptozoolology is not a science.
Because when a new species is
scientifically acknowledged, it's no
longer crypto, no longer secret, and is
therefore outside the domain of
cryptozoolology. When the unknown
becomes the known, its mystique is gone.
And the mystique is the entire point.
This is why conspiracy theorists have
always been obsessed with secret
societies like the Freemasons or the
Illuminati. What interests them is
secrecy itself. YouTube is full of
videos like hidden camera exposes
Freemason rituals or like forbidden
videos inside the Mormon temple.
Incredibly boring things become
obsessively fascinating if you simply
tell people that it's secret and they're
not allowed to know about it. The
conspiracist classic None Dare Call It
Conspiracy by Gary Allen, a major
influence on Alex Jones, describes
conspiracy research as quote history's
greatest who done it. a mystery
thriller. I think this reveals a lot
about the conspiracist mindset.
Conspiracy research is a thrillseeking
activity. People don't become conspiracy
theorists because they followed rational
arguments to an evidence-based
conclusion. Which is not to say that
conspiracy theorists aren't interested
in evidence. They're very interested in
evidence. They accumulate vast webs of
evidence. They're passionate about
investigation, about doing their own
research. 9/11 truthers will often give
at least a superficial impression of
being well-versed in structural
engineering. They present facts about
the temperature at which jet fuel burns.
They start using words like
nanoothermite. They have confident
opinions about whether building 7 could
have collapsed from fire. But I think
it's a mistake to see conspiracy
discourse as some kind of botched
attempt at rational inquiry. I don't
think it is, but why not? There's a
particular type of evidence that
conspiracy theorists usually rely on.
what they call anomalies. An anomaly is
anything that seems subjectively
suspicious, improbable, or inexplicable,
a glitch in the matrix. For example, the
Apollo 11 press conference is constantly
cited by moonlanding hoaxers because the
astronauts appear at times dejected and
morose. Conspiracy theorists interpret
this anomaly as proof that the
astronauts are being forced to
perpetrate a scam on the American
people. Poor men. clearly under threat
of death if they reveal the truth that
they went nowhere near the moon. I'm
trying to be open-minded here, but their
body language says they never went
anywhere. I've seen people more hyped
about a visit to the mall. Isn't it also
possible that they were, I don't know,
tired after flying to the moon? Because
everyone on the internet is an expert
body language analyst. So, what do I
know? In the summer of 2020, a
conspiracy theory spread on social media
claiming that missing children were
being trafficked by online furniture
retailer Wayfair. The evidence for this
conspiracy was an anomaly on Wayfair's
website, where certain pillows and
cabinets were listed for $10,000, an
outrageously inflated price. Some of
these items had names that just so
happened to correspond to names of
children who'd been reported missing.
People on Twitter started wondering,
"Wasn't it possible these children were
being sold into depraved sexual slavery
and trafficked inside of pillows and
cabinets?" A lot of people jumped to
that conclusion without stopping to
consider alternative explanations. Like,
for example, maybe there was an error on
the website. Maybe the products were
named by SEO optimization algorithms
looking for frequently searched names.
Or maybe giving human names to products
is just a fairly common marketing
practice. The Stephanie upholstered
armchair. The Vanna tufted sofa. This
one's not even on Wayfair. Adilia is at
Home Depot. My god, this goes all the
way to the top. Don't worry, Adilia.
We'll break you out of your velvet
prison. The Wayfair missing children did
later turn up, by the way. One
18-year-old girl went live on Facebook
to reassure the public that she was fine
and not in fact being sex trafficked
inside of a cabinet, but conspiracy
theorists in the chat were not relieved.
In fact, they were annoyed that their
investigation was being debunked. One
woman commented, "Put our ass back in
the cabinet." For a more convincing
example of the argument from Anomalies,
let's look at Loose Change, the 2005
documentary that defined the 9/11
truther movement. Loose change is
essentially just a big list of 9/11
anomalies, including some that actually
are pretty, well, anomalous, like the
discovery of a hijacker's passport at
ground zero. Seven different black boxes
made from the most resilient materials
known to man were all completely
destroyed beyond repair. Yet, a passport
made from a fragile material known as
paper managed to fly through a 2,000°
explosion and land undamaged blocks
away, where the FBI conveniently found
it, thereby incriminating Satam Al-
Sakami and al-Qaeda for the attacks. Who
writes this stuff? Isn't it weird that a
passport would survive a 2,000 degree
explosion? Like, yeah, it is extremely
weird. How do we explain that? Well, my
explanation is that sometimes weird
things happen. In 1987, Northwest
Airlines Flight 255 crashed shortly
after takeoff in Detroit, killing 156
people. Everyone on the plane died
except for one 4-year-old girl. How
could a 4-year-old survive a plane crash
that killed more than 100 adults? Isn't
that anomalous? It's super [ __ ]
anomalous. But you know what? Sometimes
anomalous things happen. How did the
hijacker's passport end up at ground
zero? Well, I really don't know. Maybe
God guided the passport to safety. Maybe
an al-Qaeda operative handed it to
police because they wanted to get
caught. Maybe it was planted by a
reptilian. It was me. I did it. Me and
my close personal friend Hillary
Clinton. None of this is plausible. But
is it more plausible that the Bush
administration planted such a weird
piece of ultimately superfluous evidence
in the course of orchestrating the
secret controlled demolition of the
tallest buildings in New York City and
that no one involved in any stage of
that process has leaked anything about
it for over two decades? God, am I
really debating 911 truthers online?
Have I really learned nothing in 23
years? The thing about anomalies is that
they never really amount to any kind of
substantive evidence that a conspiracy
occurred. The argument from anomalies is
often just a series of statements
beginning, "Isn't it weird? Isn't it
weird that cabinets on Wayfair are
listed for
$10,000? Oh my god, that's really
anomalous. Isn't it weird that Sirius,
the hero dog of 9/11, was photographed
with Bill Clinton exactly one year
before the attack?" Yes, it's weird. You
have proven that a weird thing happened,
but that's all you've proven. It's a
style of argument based entirely on
innuendo, conjecture, and asking leading
questions designed to push the audience
to a speculative conclusion. It's like
that History Channel show Ancient
Aliens, where the phrase, "Is it
possible?" occurs with comical
frequency. Is it possible that Bigfoot
is actually an extraterrestrial? Is it
possible the moon is not only hollow but
an artificial structure? Is it possible
that the story of the Minotaur is based
on actual events? Is it possible that
the octopus didn't originate on Earth?
Is it possible that what we have here
are
extraterrestrials wearing some type of
protective suits? Is it even possible
that Nessie is an alien entity that is
able to pass through a wormhole that
exists at Loch Ness? Like yes, lots of
things are possible because possibility
requires a very low threshold of
evidence. It's possible the moon is
controlled by reptiles. It's possible
that life is but a dream. This rhetoric
of asking leading questions functions in
part as disavowel because technically
you're not making any claims. You're
just asking questions. But it also
provokes the imagination of the audience
and makes you feel like you're
connecting the dots on your own. And
that's exciting. It's engaging. It makes
you feel smart, like you're an
independent investigator, a free
thinker. You're not a sheep who believes
whatever the mockingb birdstream media
forces down your throat. You do your own
research. But do you? No, Patrick.
Scrolling Telegram channels about how
the Knights Templar are using 5G
networks to make you eat bugs is not
research. No one likes to feel like a
passive receiver of information. Okay.
Well, some people do. Flea Bag, maybe. I
want someone to tell me what to eat,
what to like, what to hate, what to rage
about. But conspiracy theories appeal to
people who want to feel in control of
their beliefs. And I do kind of
sympathize with that. I don't want to
get knowledge cucked by some high priest
telling me what to believe. This
attitude is not at all unique to
conspiracy theorists. Individualist
skepticism is sort of the foundation of
Western philosophy. The modern era in
philosophy starts with Decart who wanted
to question everything. In the Middle
Ages, you had to accept the doctrines of
the church or they'd call you a heretic
and they'd burn you. But Deart thought
that knowledge shouldn't be based on
dogma. It should be based on reason. And
that does sound good, doesn't it? The
problem though is that if you question
everything, then how do you know that
anything is true? Decar argued you can't
even trust your own senses because you
could be dreaming right now. You could
be deceived by an evil demon. So Deart
wanted to discover an idea that could
not be doubted. And he came up with this
Latin slogan kitosum. I think therefore
I am which has to be true because it's
on t-shirts and coffee mugs. Popular
everywhere among people who want you to
know they went to college. From the kito
Decart tried to deduce that God exists
and that God wouldn't allow a demon to
deceive you. It's not a very good
argument. Decart is not a good
philosopher.
The problem is that knowledge is
inherently a collective endeavor. And
that's even more true now than it was in
Daycart's time. You can't really do
science by yourself anymore. To some
extent, you have to trust the work of
other people. Conspiracy theorists don't
trust science because science is an
institution and they don't trust
institutions. A lot of conspiracy
theorists go even further than that and
they adopt this oppositional attitude to
knowledge. In other words, whatever they
want you to believe, the opposite is
probably true. On a YouTube clip of
Richard Nixon telling Billy Graham that
there will be a poker in America if the
Jews quote don't start behaving, the top
comment reads, "I always wondered why I
was conditioned to dislike Nixon by the
media. Things are starting to make
sense." This idea that every mainstream
source of information is conditioning
from the JudeoBevik banking cabal leads
to a kind of fetish for stigmatized and
secret knowledge. Conspiracy theorists
play up how persecuted and silenced they
are because they see institutional
opposition as proof of their
correctness. An Austrian painter and
conspiracy theorist once said in his
book, "My struggle." Oh, poor baby. My
struggle. He should have just called it
my journey, my whole entire journey. He
wrote that the media's insistence on the
protocols of the elders of Zion being an
anti-semitic hoax is quote the best
proof that they are authentic. This is
one reason why conspiracy theories are
impossible to debunk. The attempt to
debunk them is seen as shilling and
therefore as proof of the conspiracy. If
it isn't true, why are you so eager to
disprove it? Conspiracists see the
media, the academy, the medical
establishment, every reputable source of
information as a kind of cartasian demon
lulling us all into a dream world from
which their goal is to awake. And it's
this experience of awakening that
conspiracy theorists are trying to
trigger with an overwhelming gish gallop
of anomalies that eventually climaxes in
a wild leap in logic. The most egregious
example of this possibly ever is the
Dutch conspiracy theorist Janet Oabard's
10-part video essay Fall of the Cabal,
which recruited millions of people into
QAnon in 2019 and 2020. Fall of the
Cabal begins with a section called
Things That Made Me Go H. What I'm going
to do is first of all give you a short
overview of things that made me go hm.
things that made me go, "hm" is just a
random list of anomalies, not arguments,
just questions. Isn't it weird? Isn't it
weird that the Vatican's audience hall
is full of references to reptilians? Did
you know the Vatican's telescope is
called Lucifer? And since when does the
Pope make the sign of the devil?
[Music]
911. Wow, that's really anomalous. Are
you aware of the fact that children
cartoons contain subliminal messages of
sex and
violence? Why? That's super [ __ ]
anomalous. Fall of the Cabal does allude
to a few things that are real. Like,
yes, Monsanto and Buyer are companies
that make carcinogenic herbicides.
That's true. But then that's just
casually mixed in with, you know, blood
liel. Do you realize that these four
skins are actually sold? That it's a
trade? What's next? Drinking baby blood?
Look, what is the point of this? There's
no logical connection between any of
these points. It's just a bunch of
ominous innuendo leading the viewer to
the vague conclusion that something
isn't adding up. We've been lied to. And
that is always the preface. We've been
lied to. What is the purpose of opening
with that? Well, if you can make your
audience feel like everything they've
ever been told is a lie, like science is
fake, like school is indoctrination, the
news is propaganda, the so-called fact
checkers are dangerous. The so-called
fact checkers are dangerous. It leaves
the audience in a very vulnerable
position because now they have nowhere
to turn for reliable information because
you've convinced them not to trust
anyone and now they don't know what to
believe. And if you're a propagandist,
that's exactly where you want them.
Because most people are uncomfortable
with doubt and uncertainty. It leaves
you open to alternative explanations,
even bad ones, because any explanation
feels better than none. So this is the
critical moment when you make the
logical leap into hyperspace. You've
broken the audience down, and now you
get to build them back up. You get to be
the Morpheus telling them how deep the
rabbit hole goes. And you may as well go
ham because at this point they'll just
believe anything you say. Get ready for
some conspiracy facts. The North
American Man Boy Love Association. This
is the mascot. Why are children exposed
to Illuminati symbols? Chemtrails.
Cannibalism. George Soros. The
Rothschild family. Follow the money.
Adrenochrome is real. It is the ultimate
drug. The same church of Satan Chelsea
Clinton is so fond of. If you can really
jump from one timeline to another
parallel one, you can time travel. I
have grown to fully trust Dawn, master
of all masters. He is a genius, a 5D
chess player, a man with a huge heart.
Hugh is not a cult.
The most insidious thing about this form
of indoctrination is that to the people
susceptible to it, it feels like
critical thinking. They think they're
connecting the dots, asking questions
the sheeple can't handle. They noticed
the anomalies. They followed the money.
No one told them what to think. Except
you kind of did tell them what to think.
You just did it in a way that made them
feel like it was their idea. And when
people feel like something is their
idea, they internalize it as part of
their identity. They become possessive
of it. Where they once may have been
open to skepticism, they'll now be on
guard against it, ready to dismiss it
reflexively as shilling. So, the point
of the argument from Anomalies is not to
support a conclusion with evidence. The
point is to trigger a crisis of belief
that primes the audience for a kind of
conversion experience, an initiation
into the cult of mystery, of secret
alternative knowledge. And that
conversion experience is called the
awakening. Going down the rabbit hole,
taking the red pill. It's hard to
overstate the influence of 1999
cyberpunk science fiction film The
Matrix. A great movie whose legacy is
unfortunately tainted by association
with every manner of Looney Tunes
buffoonery. The Matrix became the
centerpiece of 21st century mythology
that it is because its allegory of
awakening from a dream is a universal
archetype. In western philosophy,
there's Plato's cave, Decart's demon.
Lenin says the revolution will arrive
with the worker's awakening of class
consciousness. In Hindu and Buddhist
thought, the illusion is called Maya, a
deceit that conceals the true nature of
things. What's called enlightenment by
Western Buddhists is a 19th century
translation of the poly term bodhi,
which is more literally translated as
awakening. So, The Matrix can mean
whatever you want it to mean. The
directors of the movie now claim that
it's an allegory for transgender
awakening. But whatever your
interpretation, taking the red pill is
to awake from a dream world. It's a
revelation that explains the feeling
you've had all your life that something
is vaguely wrong. You don't know what it
is, but it's there like a splinter in
your mind. By taking the red pill, Neo
underos a right of passage, symbolically
dying in the dream world to be reborn in
the desert of the real. For Neo, this
also entails the realization that he is
in fact the main character of reality,
which also probably speaks to something
in the conspiracist mindset. When
conspiracy theorists tell you to wake
up, they're not trying to persuade you
about the causes of a particular
historical event. They're urging you to
transform the way you think about the
world in general. Dylan Lewis Monroe's Q
web diagram connects the dots from
Atlantis to the Rothschilds to the
Vatican to 9/11 to reptilian
extraterrestrials to Obama's fake birth
certificate. It's all connected in the Q
web. The Western pyramidal hierarchy has
been replaced with a mesmerizing eastern
tangle which the authors of
conspirituality compare to a Buddhist
mandelola meant to guide the viewer to
awakening. So, what is it the conspiracy
theorists are awakening
[Music]
to? Wake
up. Part three,
conspiracism. So, wake up to what? Well,
like every convert, conspiracists are
awakening to a new worldview, which I'm
calling conspiracism. And yes, it
deserves to be an ism because it's not a
theory. It's a way of thinking. The
details constantly change, but the
fundamental mindset remains the same. In
his 1964 essay, the paranoid style in
American politics, historian Richard
Hoffadder said that conspiracist
thinking was not unique to his own era
of hysteria about looming one world
communist government. He tracked its
roots all the way back to the founding
of the United States when there was a
panic about the Bavarian Illuminati
infiltrating the Freemasons and plotting
to replace Christianity with
jackabinical atheism. In 1798, Timothy
Dwight, president of Yale University,
said, quote, "Shall our sons become the
disciples of Voltaare and the dragoons
of Mara, or our daughters the concubines
of the Illuminati?" The concubines of
the Illuminati. I for one welcome my new
sex lord Adam vice helped. When I heard
he was professor of canon law at English
dot I was like oh my god that's so
[ __ ] hot. That same year George
Washington received a letter from a
German reverend warning him of a quote
society of freemasons that distinguishes
itself by the name of Illuminati whose
plan is to overturn all government and
all religion. This conspiracy theory was
popularized by John Robersonson's 1797
book proofs of a conspiracy against all
the religions and governments of Europe
carried on in the secret meetings of
Freemasons, Illuminati and reading
societies collected from good
authorities. Well, if it's from good
authorities. Washington wrote back,
quote, I have heard much of the
nefarious and dangerous plan and
doctrines of the Illuminati, but he
assured the minister that the Freemasons
in America were not involved. So,
conspiracism has existed for a long
time. Illuminati conspiracy nonsense
crossed George Washington's desk. But we
could go back even further than that. In
the year 64, there were conspiracy
theories that the great fire of Rome was
an inside job ordered by Emperor Nero.
Olive oil can't melt marble columns.
Nero, of course, blamed the Christians.
Christians were in many ways the Jews of
ancient Rome. Well, the Jews were also
the Jews. They often are. So, this is
not a new way of thinking. The internet
did not start this. It's actually kind
of amazing how consistent conspiracist
rhetoric is across centuries. Another
passage from that letter to Washington
reads, "Our present time, pregnant with
the most shocking evils and calamities,
threatens ruin to our liberty and
government. Secret, the most secret
plans are agitation." Like, it sounds
like someone translated Alex Jones into
18th century English. According to
Hofstatter, the paranoid style is
characterized by quote heated
exaggeration, suspiciousness, and
conspiratorial fantasy, as well as
feelings of persecution. It's
overheated, over suspicious,
overaggressive, grandiose, and
apocalyptic in expression. Sound like
anyone you know? But I think
conspiracism is more than just a
rhetorical style. It also has certain
core beliefs. Political scientist
Michael Barkon says the three principles
of conspiracism are nothing happens by
accident, nothing is as it seems, and
everything is connected. I agree, but I
want to use a slightly different
definition because I do my own research.
I'll call the three principles of
conspiracism intentionalism, dualism,
and symbolism. Now, pay attention
because this will be on the test.
Intentionalism is the idea that
everything that happens is the result of
a deliberate plan. That there are
shadowy agents of evil scheming behind
every misfortune. There are no accidents
and no significant event is the result
of mere human ignorance or incompetence
or of systemic forces beyond human
intention. Dualism is the idea that all
of human history and politics are best
understood as an epic battle between
good and evil. The forces of light
against the forces of darkness. When bad
things happen, when there are wars,
disasters, poverty, these are simply the
result of evil people doing evil things
because they're evil. And finally,
symbolism is the idea that everything
has meaning and everything is connected.
So, politics and history are sort of
astrological in nature. There are no
coincidences. Everything is teameming
with signs and symbols that we can
decode to discover the truth and define
the future. Now, these are all pretty
common patterns of thinking that most of
us slip into sometimes. And not everyone
who flirts with conspiracy theories is a
full-blown conspiracist, but people who
believe an all-encompassing super
conspiracies like QAnon, the kind of
people who think the deep state mapping
project is an accurate depiction of
reality, those people are full-blown
conspiracists. Now, let's explore the
labyrinth of their madness in
excruciating detail. It's okay. I've had
a spiritual awakening. I've learned to
enjoy losing subscribers. Conspiracist
principle one,
intentionalism. Hello, my pretties. In
October 2024, conspiracist Congresswoman
Marjgerie Taylor Green. Marjorie, if
you're watching this, I've already put a
hex on you. It's too late. In October,
Marjorie posted a series of tweets
arguing that severe hurricanes in the
southern United States were deliberately
geoengineered by government agencies to
suppress Republican voters. Damn, I wish
it worked. A year earlier, Marjorie,
[ __ ] Marjorie, tweeted that climate
change is a scam perpetrated by quote,
"very powerful people that are getting
rich beyond their wildest dreams,
convincing many that carbon is the
enemy." How can this woman believe that
anthropogenic climate change is a hoax,
but the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration is planning each specific
hurricane? Well, because she's an idiot,
but also because she's a conspiracist.
And conspiracists believe that nothing
happens by accident. So they cannot
grasp the concept that carbon emissions
might cause climate problems as an
unintended byproduct of
industrialization. But they have no
problem whatsoever believing that big
government Satanists are using harp to
create hurricanes. And the Rothschilds
are starting forest fires in California
with Jewish moon lasers. This is
intentionalism. The idea that everything
that happens is the result of someone's
plan. And if it's not immediately
obvious whose plan it is, that must be
because the plan is secret.
Conspiracists see world events as a big
puppet show. For every war, every
terrorist attack, every recession, every
pandemic, every election, revolution, or
so-called natural disaster, there must
be a man behind the curtain pulling all
the strings. In the most general sense,
intentionalism is a way of explaining
why things happen. Why does a volcano
erupt? Well, a scientist who cares about
facts and data like a cuckled might say
that the collision of tectonic plates
forces magma through cracks in the
Earth's crust, leading to an eruption.
What a coincidence, but move along
Sheeple. Nothing to see here. An
intentionalist explanation would be that
volcanoes erupt because someone makes
them erupt. And who that someone is
depends on the specifics of your
worldview. An animist or polytheist
might say that a volcano erupts because
the mountain is angry or the god of the
mountain is angry. A monotheist might
just say because God is angry. Not all
monotheists, but you know the type. Go
spawn. You just keep pushing on to the
hell where you will forever burn. And a
conspiracist might say that volcanoes
erupt because the globalists are using
volcanic smoke signals to
numerologically communicate the dates of
upcoming wars, recessions, and terrorist
attacks. I predicted in 2022 globalists
would use Mount Edna smoke rings to
signal war. They have done it before. 8
June 2000 equals 1 years 3 months 3 days
before the 9/11 attacks where buildings
collapsed. Collapse equals 133. 8 June
2000. Mount Etna smoke ring stunt
occurred on Kanye West's birthday. What
a coincidence. Kanye West and Mount Etna
have the exact same numerology.
Checkmate geologists. I at this point I
don't even know who we're checkmating.
Conspiracism is preodern thought applied
to post-modern politics. Carl Pauper
said the conspiracy theory of society
comes from abandoning God and then
asking who is in his place. Well,
apparently the globalists or the deep
state or the Illuminati, the Freemasons,
the Vatican, the World Economic Forum,
the Bilderberg Group, the Satanic Cabal,
the you know, the New York, Hollywood,
International Banking, Rothschild,
Soros, Communist, Zionists, you know the
ones. So, there is disagreement among
conspiracists about who they are, about
who controls the world, who is the
puppet master, but they all agree that
someone is. It's a kind of intelligent
design theory of world events.
Conspiracism is to politics, economics,
and apparently meteorology what
creationism is to biology. And it's
motivated by a lot of the same anxieties
and misunderstandings. Like creationists
will say, "Well, if God didn't create
mankind in his own image, then I suppose
it's just a random accident that one day
monkeys gave birth to mima." Okay, but
that's not what the theory of evolution
says. Science [ __ ] Chuck's book is not
titled On the Origin of Species by
Random Accident. Oopsy dupsy. New
species originated. No, it's on the
origin of species by natural selection.
Natural selection is not random
accident. It's a long-term process where
heritable characteristics better suited
to a part. Why am I bothering to explain
this? Why am I even making this video?
Why do anything at all? I guess for the
pleasure of rolling the boulder up the
mountain once again, one must imagine
Sisph is happy. Okay. Well, don't tell
me what to imagine. The point is
evolution doesn't need a plan. I mean,
you could argue that evolution is God's
plan. And okay, seems like a weird plan,
but it's not weirder than ordering
Abraham to sacrifice his kid and saying,
"Just kidding." At the last moment, it
was just a prank, bro. Father almost
sacrifices son. Prank gone wrong.
Hilarious. Liked and subscribed. Now,
things get a little more complicated
with history and politics because
obviously a lot of things that happen in
politics are the result of someone's
deliberate plan. Whether or not you
believe in 9/11 conspiracy theories, I
think we all agree that someone decided
to fly planes into those buildings or
holograms or whatever it is you people
think happened. Russia invaded Ukraine
presumably because Vlad Putin made a
plan. Not a good plan clearly, but
technically some kind of plan. And the
invasion of Ukraine is typical of the
way actual plans tend to play out. One,
it's a plan of a single faction, not of
some unitary global elite. And two, the
plan is marked by human frailty. It's
half-hazard. It's improvisational. It
unfolds in ways the planners didn't
anticipate. This is not how
conspiracists understand plans. In his
best-selling crackpot ravings, Behold a
Pale Horse, conspiracist William Cooper
describes his intentionalist view of
history. quote, "A grand game of chess
is being played on a level that we can
barely imagine, and we are the pawns."
He then absurdly suggests that before
continuing the book, the reader should
play quote at least two complete games
of chess, you must learn the rules they
play by. And yes, they is in all caps.
Conspiracists are incapable of any other
typographical style. Conspiracists think
that if political power seems divided
and incompetent, that's just because we
are stuck in the dream world at the
bottom of the pyramid, unaware of the
evil chess demons secretly controlling
everything. Listen to how 18th century
conspiracist Ogustan Barwell described
the secret causes of the revolution.
Quote, "Even the most horrid deeds
perpetrated during the French
Revolution, everything was foreseen and
resolved on, was combined and
premeditated. They were the offspring of
deep thought villain since they had been
prepared and were produced by men who
alone held the clue of those plots and
conspiracies lurking in the secret
meetings where they had been conceived.
This is not how things actually happened
though, Augustan. An event like the
French Revolution is too complicated to
be the result of a perfectly executed
master plan. But just like creationists,
conspiracists often fail to even
understand the alternative to
intelligent design. Conspiracist Gary
Allen writes, "There are really only two
theories of history. Either things
happen by accident and neither planned
nor caused by anybody, or they happen
because they are planned and somebody
causes them to happen." This is a false
dichotomy. We don't have to choose
between the conspiracist view of history
as a masterful game of chess and the
straw man alternative that everything
happens by accident for no reason.
That's not what mainstream historians
are saying. They don't think the French
Revolution was an accident. They just
think the causes are complex. From the
Enlightenment to inherent tensions of
the estate system to harvest failures in
the 1780s. And yes, obviously various
people involved in the revolution made
plans, but none of those people were
masterminds secretly controlling every
twist and turn, which if you put on your
Sherlock Holmes hat, you should probably
be able to deduce from the fact that
most of them were guillotined. Masterful
gambit citizen. Intentionalism
especially runs rampant in the way
people talk about the economy. A topic
where most people are a little
conspiracist. You know why did the price
of eggs go up? It must be because the
president turned up the big red
inflation dial on his desk. Not that the
president has no control over the
economy. You know, he can appoint the
Federal Reserve chair. He can propose
taxes, tariffs, wars, that sort of
thing. But a lot of times blaming the
president for the price of gas and eggs
makes about as much sense as sacrificing
the king because the river flooded. It
feels good to blame someone, but in
reality there's not a single person on
this earth who can precisely predict,
much less control the economy. And
that's sort of creepy, right? Like the
whole world revolves around money, but
money is this weird abstraction you have
to do math to understand. Most people
aren't up for that. So we talk about the
economy like it's an angry volcano god.
Conspiracists really love to literalize
the invisible hand. William Cooper
claims that for the secret elites, it is
as easy to predict and control the trend
of an economy as to predict and control
the trajectory of a projectile. The
economy has been transformed into a
guided missile on target. So, who is
launching this missile? Whose hand is
the invisible hand? Well, conspiracists
usually say that it's the international
banking cabal or the Rothschild
controlled central banks or a bunch of
other words that basically mean Jews.
Again, more on that later. To actually
understand the economy, you would have
to use scientific systematic thinking,
not animistic, intentionalist conspiracy
thinking. In a way, every systematic
theorist from Milton Freriedman to Karl
Marx is closer to being correct than
literally every conspiracy theorist. And
yet, even the most systematic thinkers
still rely on intentionalist metaphors
to communicate their ideas. When Adam
Smith wanted to describe how the
preference for doing business at home
leads merchants pursuing their
self-interest to also unintentionally
promote the good of their country, he
said they're led by an invisible hand.
When Karl Marx wanted to describe the
extraction of surplus value from the
working class, he said capital is dead
labor that acts like a vampire. It comes
to life when it drinks living labor. And
the more living labor it drinks, the
more it comes to life. An invisible hand
that guides us. Vampires drinking blood.
These are anthropomorphic metaphors that
describe an unintentional pattern as if
it were an intentional action. So why
use these metaphors? Well, because this
is how humans think. We make sense of
the world by imagining it as a
reflection of ourselves. We see the
earth as a mother and the sun as a
father. We imagine an economy with
hands, capital with fangs, and the
universe itself with a mind like our own
but greater, which we call God. I don't
think it's stupid to think this way. I
just think it's human. Humans think
humanishly. So, some level of
intentionalism is probably inevitable.
We sort of can't help it. It's one
reason why conspiracy explanations of
events are so appealing, and it's
compounded by a few other motives.
Motive one is the denial of chaos. I'm
sorry. I know we're like three
subsections deep. Unlike better
YouTubers, I have not succeeded at
organizing this video into an internet
friendly numbered list. It's scary to
become an adult and to realize that in
fact, your parents don't know what
they're doing and no one knows what
they're doing. There really are no
grown-ups. Not in the way you thought
when you were a kid. It's unnerving to
think that no one is steering the ship.
So even if the deep state puppeteers are
evil, it's maybe reassuring to think
that at least someone somewhere is in
control. Someone is daddy. You know,
it's like daddy arrived and he's taking
his belt off. Motive two is the denial
of collective action. Why would August
Barwell want to think that the French
Revolution was an Illuminati master
plan? Well, because he was a Catholic
monarchist. So it was ideologically more
convenient for him to think secret
societies planned the revolution than to
accept that it wasn't any sense of the
people. It's like the American
conservatives in the 1950s who could not
imagine why anyone would choose to be a
communist. So they assumed it must be
water fidation and manurion
brainwashing. or like the conservatives
today who see every progressive social
movement from LGBT rights to Antifa to
Black Lives Matter as top-down plots
perpetrated by Soros funded crisis
actors on behalf of the global homo woke
agenda. Motive three is proportionality
bias. The tendency to assume that major
events must have major causes. The idea
that a world historic disaster like the
CO 19 pandemic could be caused by
something so trivial and accidental as a
bat virus being transmitted to humans
via pengalins or whatever. It feels
narratively imbalanced. It's more
satisfying to imagine that it all
unfolded according to a master plan of a
secret global conspiracy to control the
human race with face masks and arrows on
the floor of the grocery store. Wake up,
sheeple. Motive four is the need for
someone to blame. This, I think, is the
big one. Whose fault is it is a very
important human question. The elites are
the reason I get no women. I know this
may sound crazy, but retaliation is an
instinctive reaction to injury. When
something goes wrong, we look for
someone to punish, even if it's not
really anyone's fault. When a storm
destroyed his bridge, the Persian king
Xerxes supposedly ordered his men to
whip the sea as punishment according to
Herodotus. So probably that didn't
happen. You can't trust what a Greek
says about Persians. I'm always saying
that. But there's also real examples.
During the Black Death, Jews were
falsely blamed for poisoning wells and
were massacred in pograms across Europe.
In 2020, Trump called COVID the China
virus, using a similar kind of scapegoat
logic to direct populist rage at
foreigners, which is the entire thing he
does. It's all he does. At the height of
the pandemic, millions of people viewed
the Plemic trilogy of conspiracy
documentaries, which falsely claimed the
virus was deliberately engineered as
part of a global conspiracy to take our
freedoms. Pandemic provided scapegoats
by making cartoonish villains out of
everyone from Anthony Fouchy to Bill
Gates to the WH, WF, CDC, CCP, John D.
Rockefeller, big pharma, global
communist agenda. And it's not that no
one deserves any blame for the way the
pandemic was handled. The 10 richest men
in the world doubled their wealth in the
same two years that millions of people
slid into poverty. I think that's worth
being angry about. that the conspiracist
tendency is not to blame opportunists
taking advantage of unjust systems and
perverse incentives. And it's certainly
not to blame the systems and incentives
themselves. No, conspiracists demand
blood. So they seek out secret covens of
witches and reptiles and Satanists whom
they imagine are motivated by pure
ontological evil. Speaking of which,
conspiracist principle two, dualism.
Dualism is the idea that society and
maybe even reality itself is a struggle
of good against evil, light against
dark. There's a battle being fought over
our heads for world
dominance. A battle between good and
evil. Either you are with us or you are
with the terrorists.
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll quote another Marjory tweet cuz she
thinks with the same subtlety that she
does pull-ups. quote, "We are in a
battle between good and evil. The
Democrats are the party of pedophiles,
murdering the innocent unborn, etc.,
etc. The Democrat party is flatout evil,
and yesterday they tried to murder
President Trump." Imagine the Democrats
attempting something as proactive as an
assassination. Not really their MMO, is
it? Dualism is a view of human behavior
devoid of moral ambiguity where people
do bad things not because of ignorance
or a misbegotten sense of righteousness,
but because they have consciously sworn
allegiance to the forces of evil. And it
must be a great confidence boost to
people who think this way to know that
because they haven't sworn allegiance to
evil, they must be on the side of
righteousness in everything they do.
Sometimes people call this man thinking
in reference to the religion founded by
the ancient prophet Mani who taught that
there is not one god but two opposing
powers. The father of greatness versus
the prince of darkness. But I feel like
calling it manon evades the fact that
most people who think this way are well
followers of more popular religions. So
I'm calling it dualism. Now I'll just
say it. Dualism is wrong. The world is
not a battle between light and dark.
Light and dark are complimentary and
codependent. And I know that's true
because it was revealed to me by the
Archangel Medatron in a mystical vision
I had after consuming some sacred plant
medicine from the mother earth.
Checkmate, Manakans. Sometimes the best
way to test an idea is to look at the
other things it leads people to believe.
So let's look at some dualist thinking
in action. In May 2024, Buckingham
Palace unveiled Jonathan Yo's portrait
of King Charles III, which depicts the
monarch against a red background evoking
like a sea of blood and fire. Normal
people agreed that this was funny, but
conspiracists flushed to social media to
speculate that Kate Middleton was dead
and the portrait was painted with her
blood and that vertically mirroring the
painting along its right edge reveals
the face of Satan, prince of darkness.
Conspiracist Naomi Wolf quote, "These
Satanists just don't sleep. My god, it
was really bad for your skin to not
sleep. That's probably why they need the
adrenochrome." So, look, I agree that
the king is bad. We're on the same page
there. But he's not bad because he's a
secret Satan worshipper who hides
demonic images and oil paintings. No,
the king is bad because, prepare
yourself, Brits, yank take incoming.
Because monarchy is bad. But
conspiracists do not understand that
problems can arise from a form of
government itself. For conspiracists,
the problem is never the structure of
power, but rather that the people
currently in power just so happen to be
evil Satanists. Listen to how QAnon
propaganda film Q the plan to save the
world directed by Joe M describes the
root of all societal problems. We were
taught that capitalism was the cause of
a massive rich poor divide and the
reason for poverty. Others were taught
that communism, the system of equal
wealth across all people, was really to
blame for the mess. But you see, folks,
it is none of these things. What you
must learn is that it was the criminals
all along. What you must learn is that
it has always been them, a colossal
global criminal class. Joe M argues that
inequality, crime, and war are not the
result of any particular political
order, but are the result of satanic
criminals taking over government,
industry, media, and banking, and
deliberately oppressing us, the good
people, by attacking the family,
poisoning our food, and murdering our
beautiful dead wife, JFK. Rest in peace,
sweet angel. The world is currently
experiencing a dramatic covert war of
biblical proportions. Literally the
fight for Earth between the forces of
good and evil. The apocalyptic tone
conceals a kind of optimism. If we could
just purge the deep state, then all the
world's problems would be solved. No
more war, no more poverty, no more
crime, because all of that is the
deliberate plan of the ontologically
evil cabal and their mainstream media
shills. We realized that the problem was
never capitalism or socialism, Democrat
or Republican, black or white, Muslim or
Christian. We know it was just very
powerful criminals who had too much
power. It can be tempting to think that
conspiracists are confused socialists
since they're seemingly so bothered by
rich elites. But they're not socialists.
They think both capitalists and
socialists are bad because they're all
puppets of the real satanic power behind
the throne. Some conspiracy theories
like QAnon are very explicit that the
enemy is literally Satan. But
conspiracist dualism can also be a
little more subtle than the least subtle
it is possible to be. John Burcher style
anti-communist conspiracy theories of
the last century usually didn't mention
Satan specifically, but the way they
told it, communism may as well have been
the devil. When conspiracists like Alex
Jones or his major influence Gary Allen
rant about communism, they're not
talking about actual communist theory or
practice. Like, here's how Gary Allen
defines communism. And yes, the
definition is in all caps. Quote, "An
international conspiratorial drive for
power on the part of men in high places
willing to use any means to bring about
their desired aim, global conquest." He
argues that Karl Marx was merely a
pathy, a pamphlete and hired goon of the
Illuminati communist bankers. That no
one in power ever sincerely believed
that communism is good because he
defines communism as a plan to
consciously do evil. Quote, "The issue
very simply is the enslavement of you
and your children." The idea of satanic
elites was taken to its extreme by new
age conspiracist David Ike, who
popularized the theory that the secret
rulers of the world are literally
inhuman. That they're shape-shifting,
bloodrinking extraterrestrial reptiles
who are using a metaphysical construct
called the Saturn Moon Matrix to
imprison humanity in a simulation with
bad
vibes. Maybe ease up on the red pills
there, buddy. I think you've had enough.
We need red pill narcans. We're losing
him. To illustrate why dualism is wrong,
let's use MK Ultra as an example. Why
did MK Ultra happen? Did the CIA
experiment with mind control because
they were Satanists who delight in doing
evil? No, that's not how things happen.
In all of human history, almost nothing
has happened because of Satanists. The
CIA wanted to develop mind control
because they were good American patriots
with a paranoid conspiratorial streak of
their own. They saw videos of American
prisoners of war in Korea declaring
allegiance to communism. And instead of
concluding that this was the result of
torture or genuine disillusionment with
what America was doing in Korea, the CIA
feared that the communists had developed
mind control and they would not allow a
mind control gap. So they didn't think
they were doing evil. They thought of
themselves as protecting the free world
against an existential threat. And when
those are the stakes, the ends justify
the means. And that is how you end up
seated in front of a one-way mirror
watching prostitutes poison people with
LSD. If you're a fed, I just do it for
fun. This is not to deny there was an
element of sadism involved in MK Ultra.
In fact, I'm sure there was. This man
worked on some of these programs. He
would write of his work, "It was fun,
fun, fun." From brothel, an agent says,
"We learned a lot about human nature in
the bedroom." But sadism usually finds a
justification for itself. Conspiracists
have never heard the saying that the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions. The final element of
conspiracist dualism is what's called
millinarianism. The idea that the battle
between good and evil is reaching an
imminent climax resulting in a messianic
age. Raging around us is the final phase
of a vast global shadow war. Not between
nations, but between the forces of good
and the most unimaginable of evils. For
KQanon, the day of judgment was the
storm. And it's not an exaggeration to
say that many viewed and at time of
filming still view Trump as the messiah.
I have grown to fully trust Dawn, master
of all masters. Conspiracists of every
era usually believe that total ruin or
total transformation is at hand. The
survival of the free world depends on
the sheeple waking up. The truth will
shake the earth to its foundations. Alex
Jones has been saying for 25 years that
tyranny is imminent. One world
government, nuclear apocalypse, World
War II, civil war alert. The globalists
are always just about to make that final
move. any day now. It's why you need to
stay tuned in to Infowars for tomorrow's
news today. And while you're here,
please buy our super male vitality serum
to purify your precious bodily fluids
and help us pay our defamation damages.
But researchers say some of Jones's
supplements could be sperm killing.
Conspiracist principle three, symbolism.
[Music]
So to show you what I mean by symbolism,
I'm just going to list some things I
have seen cited as evidence of a global
satanic conspiracy. Corporate logos that
look like the planet Saturn, the monster
energy drink symbol, the statue of Shiva
at CERN, subliminal sexual imagery in
Disney movies, red shoes, celebrities
holding pizza boxes, celebrities making
hand signs, hidden in plain sight, Tom
Hanks saluting the Baffomet and Forest
Gump. Sir, I would like to introduce you
to the Congressional Medal of Honor. US
Congressional Medal of Honor, killing
for Lucifer. Tom Ax is another Satanist
and Pedo and of course the godamn
reptiles. Isn't it weird that the
Vatican's audience hall is full of
references to reptilians? If Satanists
took over the Vatican, would you notice?
Therefore, they openly showcase their
symbolism. Therefore, they were sloppy.
If you fold a dollar bill the right way
and place it side by side, it reveals a
reptilian face with sharp teeth. And
beneath those teeth, Satan. There's a
whole genre of conspiracy theories based
on symbolism in US currency. The Eye of
Providence, and the dollar bill is the
most famous, but the Kansas hole goes
deeper than that. $5 bill shows the Twin
Towers. $10 bill shows after the planes
collided. $20 bill shows the buildings
collapsing. $50 bill shows the dust and
the smoke. $100 bill shows a new
beginning. The money is all shaped like
an airplane. Yes. All money is shaped
like an airplane if you fold it in the
shape of an airplane. What a
coincidence. Move along. Nothing to see
here.
You don't want my dollar back. Is this
what they mean by follow the money?
Okay. So, corporate logos, hand signs in
music videos, images in Hollywood
movies, occult symbols on currency. What
kind of evidence is this? is a style of
conspiracism made explicit by one of Q's
recurring slogans. Symbolism will be
their downfall. The idea is you can
define the existence and nature of a
conspiracy by learning to read the
symbolic language of the elite. QAnon
formalized this decoding activity
through Q drops or breadcrumbs, cryptic
messages that followers had to bake or
decipher. Like an army of digital ais,
we connect the dots. It's a gamification
of political speculation that's been
compared to an ARG. It's exciting to
discover secrets, uncover plots, solve
puzzles, decrypt codes, connect the
dots, divine the future. It's a
discourse that's not even
pseudointellectual because it's not even
trying to appear rational. It's most
closely related to occult divinatory
practices like astrology or tarot
reading. I call it mediammancy. If
cardamomcy is divination by reading
cards and necromancy is divination by
talking to dead people, then
mediiammancy is divination by
interpreting satanic Illuminati symbols
and Taylor Swift music videos.
Conspiracist symbolism views the media,
the iconography of government, industry,
and religion. Even the events of history
itself, as so many tea leaves in which
you can divine the true nature of
reality and predict the wicked schemes
of the elite. Oh my god, the Statue of
Liberty is actually Lucifer. Oh my god,
the One World Trade Center looks like a
syringe.
Vaxed. Conspiracists usually believe
that the news is fake, that every
official source of information is
propaganda for the cabal, and yet it's
also full of cryptic hints and symbols
which we can decode and piece together
to reveal the hidden truth. Now, a
rational person might ask, what do the
elites gain by this? Why would they
place these symbols everywhere for us to
find? Well, to mock us. They're doing it
out in the open. Normalizing Satanism is
a stage, a milestone on the road to the
new world order. It is a method of
satanic inversion, of turning white into
black and good into evil. A casual
reminder that Taylor Swift is literally
normalizing Satanism. So, the idea is
that the elites are evil occultists, so
they put evil occult symbols everywhere
because that's what evil occultists do.
I don't think treating this like a
rational argument will get us anywhere.
So, let's instead try to make sense of
it by comparison with astrology. Now, I
need to clarify my view of astrology
because by comparing it to conspiracism,
it might sound like I have a negative
opinion of astrology. So, I need to
tread carefully here or I'll be forever
exiled from the LGBT community. More so,
I think astrology has its place so long
as astrology knows its place. And the
essential guide to practical astrology,
April Elliot Kent writes, "Astrology is
a language. It's the sky's way of
speaking to us. Taken literally, this is
intentionalism. The sky does not speak
any more than volcanoes get angry. But
taken metaphorically, it could be true
that contemplating planetary cycles
causes me to realize something about my
own emotions. Like for example, that I
have bipolar disorder. If that wasn't
obvious from, you know, look around us.
In my opinion, when astrologers are
asked to explain themselves, they should
say something like this. Astrology is a
centuries old tradition of storytelling
that uses a symbolic language based
around the movement of the planets to
provide meaning and guidance to people's
lives. All human thinking is to some
extent projection. Like what is a
constellation? It's connecting the dots
in the most literal sense. The
constellation Aries is a ram. But is the
ram in the sky or is the ram in our
minds? It doesn't even really look like
a ram to me. But it wasn't named by me.
was named by ancient people who spent a
lot more time around sheep. Human brains
search for patterns. It's called
apeenia, the tendency to perceive
meaningful connections between unrelated
things. It's why we look at clouds and
see animals. It's why we look at
Disney's The Little Mermaid and see the
fallace of the father. I set certain
rules and I expect those rules to be
obeyed. And when dad gets home, you know
what he says?
You've been a bad girl.
You've been a bad little girl and you're
getting a vigorous spanking right now.
It's daddy, you [ __ ] Where's my
bourbon? Our brains default to apophenia
whenever we have no better methods of
analysis. You see this a lot on low
information investing forums like Wall
Street Bets. Low information investing.
So gambling on gambling forums, gaps in
financial literacy are spontaneously
filled by stone age superstition. The
Nvidia line made a shape and then go up.
The Tesla line made a similar shape.
Maybe it'd go up. Guys, at this point,
just consult the entrails of beasts like
honest barbarians. Stockobsessed Gen Z
are using astrology and tarot to invest.
My god, the S&P 500 is in retrograde.
Well, by the retrograde, not only do we
recognize patterns where there aren't
any, but also our preconceived biases
influence the type of patterns that we
recognize. It's like people who go
looking for God tend to find the God
they're looking for. The Virgin Mary
tends to appear on grilled cheese
sandwiches in Miami, while the name of
Allah tends to appear on melons in
Indonesia. And conspiracists who think
the world is ruled by a satanic cabal
tend to find demonic symbols basically
everywhere. Sam Smith and the weekend
with some of the most satanic
performances ever. With a literal six on
her head, Daic and all these other
artists. Do you guys get it yet? An
especially powerful type of epiphania is
called face paridolia. the tendency to
see faces in inanimate objects. Almost
any symmetrical object with two dots
over a line we perceive as a face. It's
why emojis and emoticons can convert
facial expressions with such little
information. And a guaranteed way to
create a symmetrical image is to mirror
literally any picture along a vertical
line. To choose a random example, if we
were to take the portrait of King
Charles, conspiracism is to history and
media analysis as astrology is to
astronomy, preodern thinking, postmodern
politics. And this is a little awkward
for Christian conspiracy theorists
because they're basically practicing a
form of occult divination. But that
cognitive dissonance is easily managed
by projecting their obsession with the
occult onto the elite. It's because the
elites are obsessed with the occult that
everywhere I look, I see occult symbols.
The elite, again, the so-called
establishment kings are obsessed with
the occult. Conspiracists hate the
occult. The way a man posts rants about
the evils of pornography 20 seconds
after zipping up his pants. The way the
Ku Klux Clan hated Catholicism while
parading around in Spanish Catholic
capiote hoods. Sometimes haters are fans
in denial. So why does a cult symbolism
have so many fans? Well, like
intentionalism, I think a rational
symbolic thinking is inherently human
and will never go away. Academic history
and political science will never fully
replace conspiracism for the same
reasons that astronomy will never
completely replace astrology. Because
the scientific worldview cannot meet all
human needs. Science tells us how things
happen, but it doesn't tell us why
things happen. In a certain humanistic
sense, we rely on symbolism, on
mythology to inscribe the world with
meaning. And science destroys that
mythology. Conspiracism is like
spirituality and that it re-enchants the
world. It
remthizes. It denies the meaninglessness
of random chaos on one hand and the
determinism of scientific laws on the
other. Divination survives and thrives
in the age of science because there's
important questions that scientific
rationality cannot answer. Questions
like, "How do I make sense of grief or
trauma?" Science doesn't answer
questions like that. So, we all practice
some form of witchcraft, whether it's
prayer, astrology. I mean, I believe in
psychoanalysis. There has to be a point
at which dad comes home. It's like daddy
arrived and he's taking his belt off.
You know, when something horrible like
9/11 happens, we want to know why. Not
just in a structural engineering sense.
We want it to mean something. It's not
why in the sense of physical causation.
It's why in the sense of my god, why
have you forsaken me? What is the
meaning of this? 15 years ago, I came
across this conspiracist breakdown of
the occult numerology of 9/11. It uses
numerology, tarot, and kabala to
discover the esoteric meaning of 9/11.
quote, "A mass sacrifice ritual invoking
destruction of the divine union to
provoke a response of blind violence
based in fear." There's a kind of
proportionality bias here, too.
Meaningful events should have meaningful
causes. Maybe this 9/11 ritual meme
brought some kind of comfort to the
person who made it. And is that so
wrong? If it's okay to use astrology to
make sense of personal trauma, then is
it really so bad to use conspiracist
media mansy to make sense of political
trauma? Well, yes. Yes, it is. Why?
Divination has its place as long as
divination knows its place. And
conspiracist divination never knows its
place. It's virtually always in conflict
with more rational ways of understanding
politics. And for that reason, it's a
menace to democracy. A voter who's
engaging with politics by searching for
reptilian symbols and public
architecture is not fact-checking claims
about immigrants eating pets, much less
developing informed opinions about
tariffs. And worse, the confirmation
bias and unfalsifiability of symbolic
interpretation means that every
prejudice is amplified to extremes and
immunized against debunking. If
conspiracists are homophobic, they'll
divine symbolic evidence of a gay
conspiracy. If they're anti-Semitic,
they'll divine symbolic evidence of a
Jewish conspiracy. And if they're 46% of
Trump voters in 2016, they'll conclude
on the basis of symbolism and artwork
owned by Tony Podesta and references to
hot dogs and Hillary Clinton's emails
that Democratic politicians are enacting
satanic pedo rituals in the basement of
a pizza parlor. What is it about rituals
in particular that is so endlessly
fascinating to conspiracists? 9/11 is a
ritual. Celebrities in drag is a ritual.
celebrities out of drag is a ritual. The
conspiracy theory is never just that the
elites are abusing children. It's always
specifically ritual abuse or ritual
murder. So, what is so important about
rituals? I want to go down that rabbit
hole, but it's definitely going to get
me demonetized. So, I'd like to take a
moment to thank this video's sponsors.
The Clinton Foundation, the Bilderberg
Group, Bohemian Club, the Scottish Rate
of Freemasonry, the Council on Foreign
Relations, World Bank, the Trilateral
Commission, the Jesuit Order, the
Chinese Communist Party, the Temple of
Satan, the Rothschild Estate, Galactic
Emperor Zenu, and Curiosity Stream. Just
kidding. I'll be lying in the cold dead
ground before I take a goddamn scent
from Curiosity Stream. I have a little
thing called
[Music]
integrity. Part four, the
ritual. Dark
mother, cold
mother, cruel mother.
[Music]
What is the
password?
No, I mean the Wi-Fi password. I can't
get any signal out here, which is why I
wish we'd do this in the city so I don't
have to drive out to New Jersey in the
middle of the night every time we have a
goddamn orgy. So, there's this fixation
among conspiracists on the real and
imagined rituals of the elite. For
example, the transvestigation conspiracy
theory alleges that virtually every
celebrity is secretly transgender due to
some kind of elite luciferian initiation
ritual as evidenced by, for example,
this diagram of World War II General
Douglas MacArthur's voluuptuous female
breasts. We're through the looking glass
here, people. To understand this
obsession, we need to ask, what is the
purpose of ritual? Well, ritual binds
communities together. And like
symbolism, ritual creates meaning and
clarifies social status. Coronations,
inaugurations, weddings, the reading of
a judicial verdict, all of these are
rituals that authorize certain
relationships of power. So it makes
sense that if there were secret powers
behind the throne, then those powers
would have secret rituals. And
conspiracists often tried to demonstrate
the existence of the secret powers by
exposing the secret rituals. In the late
90s, there was a young conspiracy
theorist who hosted a local radio show
in Austin, Texas. His name was Alex
Jones. One of his first moments in the
national spotlight was his Y2K video,
Dark Secrets, Inside Bohemian Grove. I
have a copy right here on VHS. Let's
watch it now. Hello, I'm Alex Jones and
I'm a radio and television host based in
Austin, Texas. And for many years, I've
been exposing the criminal activities of
the global elite, also known as the New
World Order. In this video, Alex
infiltrates the Bohemian Club, which is
essentially a fraternity for rich
middle-aged men who meet yearly at a
campground north of San Francisco to
perform a ceremony called the Cremation
of Care, in which an effigy representing
the dull cares of daily life is burnt at
an altar beneath a giant statue of an
owl. Participants in this cheeky frat
boy pageant have included presidents
Bush Jr. and senior Reagan, Eisenhower,
Hoover, and Richard Nixon, who once
referred to the cremation of care as
quote, "the mosty godamned thing you
could ever imagine." Alex insists we
should all be horrified by the cremation
of care, which he describes as an
ancient Canaanite Luciferian Babylon
mystery
religion ceremony. The centerpiece of
the documentary is a secret footage Alex
took of the ceremony, which is simply
embarrassing for everyone involved.
Beyond all care, and all the winds make
without fellowships, eternal flame once
again. Midsummer sets us free.
[Applause]
See, this is why I don't hang out with
rich people. They're not cool. Stop
making them look cool, Alex. The
documentary ends with Alex standing
outside the Texas capital building with
a megaphone, screaming about how then
Governor George Bush is a Luciferian
occultist. This is how George Bush
dresses right here when he's in the
Bohemian Grove. He is nothing but a
Luciferian twit. A Luciferian twit.
Bush. He may be on.
[Applause]
Okay, this is a little bit charming. I
admit I kind of enjoy Alex Jones early
work before he went mainstream. The
whole point of the Bohemian Grove video
is Alex seems to think that this mock
ritual sacrifice is something that
should shock us to the core. He also
absurdly implies that real child
sacrifices take place at Bohemian Grove
despite the fact that he has the whole
thing on video and clearly no children
are sacrificed. mock human
sacrifices they claim just shocks the
very foundations of what Americans
believe their leaders to be. It's like
when conspiracists site Marina
Abramovich performance art or the
Rothschild surrealist ball as evidence
of elite satanic cannibalism. You know,
because one time someone ate a cake
shaped like a person. Did you ever eat a
gingerbread man? Are you a cannibal?
Don't be stupid. You're a monster. You
know, ancient Romans accused Christians
of cannibalism because they talk of
eating and drinking their god.
Christians of all people should
understand the concept of a symbolic
human sacrifice. Isn't that like the
entire basis of your religion? What
exactly is so horrifying about a bunch
of old men getting drunk in the woods
and doing fruity rituals? We do still
have freedom of religion in this
country, which means you're allowed to
do whatever fruity rituals you want. I
think there is a grain of truth though
in conspiracist paranoia about secret
societies like the Bohemian Club or the
Bilderberg Group or maybe early in
American history the Freemasons. But it
has nothing to do with rituals. The
grain of truth is that there is
something undemocratic about a bunch of
men with a disproportionate grip on
power gathering behind closed doors. If
that's your argument, then I agree. But
that's not what conspiracists are
saying. They're not saying that secret
societies are undemocratic. They're
saying that secret societies are satanic
and that's why they're fixated on the
rituals. They think the rituals are
satanic and therefore they suspect that
child sacrifice is involved. Okay, so we
finally arrived at satanic ritual baby
killing. The moment you've all been
waiting for. Satanic ritual baby killing
is a classic conspiracy trope with a
long and ugly history. In the Middle
Ages, ritual child murder was an
accusation made in witch trials and an
anti-Jewish blood liel. In the US, one
of the best-selling books of the 1830s
was an anti-atholic hoax called awful
disclosures of Maria Monk, which claimed
that so-called black nuns were forcing
initiates to have debauched sex with
local priests and that the resulting
babies were baptized, strangled, and
buried in secret tombs beneath the
convent. This was part of a nivist
backlash against immigrants from Ireland
and Germany along with a bunch of other
conspiracy theories about a papist plot
to destroy America through mass
migration secretly subsidized by the
Catholic powers of Europe. People in
this country truly never learn.
Meanwhile, in the Catholic powers of
Europe, a panic occurred in the 1880s
when a series of books exposed a secret
luciferian cult within Freemasonry that
worshiped Ba'am, held satanic orgies,
and was plotting to destroy the papacy.
This was all revealed to be a hoax by
the writer Lao Taxile in 1897. Not that
that stops conspiracists from treating
it as fact to this day. You know, maybe
the decline in Freemasonry is the reason
there's a male loneliness epidemic. Stop
posting incel [ __ ] online and join your
local Masonic lodge.
Devil worship, exposing Satan's
underground. In the 1980s, this is
getting old fast, there was a witch hunt
known as the Satanic Panic.
We have to give a blood sacrifice to
Satan. An obsessive fascination with sex
and drugs and yes, heavy metal rock and
roll. The other face of adult Satanism
is violent and fish centered on sexual
ritual and torture, frequently
descending into the violist crime of
all, sexual abuse of children. Dungeons
and Dragons. Some claim it's a simple
harmless game. It's all
imagination, is it?
The Satanic Panic began in Canada with
the publication of Michelle Remembers, a
supposedly non-fiction memoir recounting
Catholic psychiatrist Lawrence Pastor's
hypnotherapy sessions with his patient
turned wife, Michelle Smith. In a
hypnotic trance, Michelle allegedly
recovered repressed memories of being
surrendered by her mother at the age of
five to a satanic cult whose rituals
included demonic
orgies, Bible defecation, forced
cannibalism, serpent fornication, kitten
sacrifice, baby crucifixion. This
apparently very convincing testimony was
promoted by Oprah and spread worldwide
with 12,000 accusations of satanic
ritual abuse leading to dozens of
convictions and years of jail time for
innocent daycare workers. Certain
American police officers even appointed
themselves leaders of the Grand
Inquisition, resulting in the certified
VHS classic law enforcement guide to
satanic cults. Let's watch it now.
There's two different communities that
use this park. Uh one is the uh pagan or
occultic community and the other
community is of course the homosexual
community. Interestingly enough, uh they
go hand in hand. All law enforcement
officers should be familiar with the
different types of degeneracy. This is
uh the way cultists tell each other,
"Hey, we're Satanists and we're
partying." More than 2 million American
children each year are reported missing.
The ceremonies involve rape and sexual
assault, sodomy, animal and human
sacrifices, and often the slaughter of
unbaptized infants. Sex with demons is
primary. My favorite part of this video
is where they just list a series of
atrocities supposedly committed by
Satanists, but there's this '8s synth
funk in the background the entire time.
sexual trafficking of
children, corpse
theft, pornography. So with Pizzagate,
QAnon, and the general satanic pedo
cabal conspiracies, these same satanic
ritual abuse accusations are directed
not at witches, Jews, Freemasons,
Catholics, or daycare workers, but at
the elites. And because this is
primarily a right-wing conspiracy
theory, the elites in question are
mainly Hollywood actors and liberal
politicians. Now, we have to acknowledge
another grain of truth here. The idea of
elite sex criminals seems plausible to
people in part because there are in fact
numerous elite sex criminals. Godamn
Jeffrey Epstein gave a lot of
credibility to this. However, there is a
considerable gap between Jeffrey
Epstein, the real life sex criminal,
well, the real dead sex criminal, and
the conspiracist fantasy of the satanic
pedo cabal. For one thing, there's no
evidence that Epstein was a Satanist.
And according to the victims, you know,
if you actually care what the victims
have to say, he was, if anything,
unceremonious. So why then did he commit
his crimes if not for the sake of evil
occultic rituals? Well, I think it's
safe to infer he was basically a high
libido sociopath with enough power to
get away with it. And it also seems like
beautiful girls were a kind of status
symbol to him and a currency he could
use to influence other powerful men. You
know what the real conspiracy is?
Patriarchy, fun. When you strip away the
fantasy of satanic rituals, what Jeffrey
Epstein actually did is he treated women
and girls like commodities. And I think
it's emotionally challenging for people
to confront that because treating women
and girls like commodities is benol.
It's ordinary. Most men do it to some
extent. And not because men are
inherently evil, but because society
empowers them to do it. Hey, when you're
a star, they let you do it. You can do
anything. Whatever you want. Grab them
by the
You can do anything. And because this is
the internet, I need to clarify that I
don't hate men. I'm not trying to
castrate anyone. I'm not trying to
cuckold anyone. I'm not trying to strap
on a high heeled boot and step on
anyone's andor but I'm just I'm just
asking questions. Why didn't Trump's
grab him by the [ __ ] boast end his
political career in 2016? Well, because
men say things like that all the time.
Male sexual domination is normal. But
Epstein crossed a line. He took it too
far. And there's a need to make that
line as sharp as possible to distance
criminal sexual domination from normal
sexual domination. And that is one
function of the satanic ritual abuse
conspiracy. It denies the benality of
sexual violence by making sexual
violence exotic. Conspiracists project
sexual violence outside themselves,
outside their own families, communities,
and churches by imagining it as this
bizarre, incomprehensible evil practiced
by spiritually deviant elites with
motives that resemble nothing in
ordinary human psychology. And that way,
we never have to confront the hypocrisy
of our own values. That we idealize
alpha male sexual dominance, but we're
horrified when powerful men sexually
dominate. We make a fetish out of
youthful beauty, but we're horrified
when someone is sexually attracted to
the exact quality we've all been
collectively fetishizing. Like, we
haven't all heard ordinary men say that
women hit the wall at 25. I don't need
to show the OkayCid data, do I? Like, it
isn't common place to tell teenage girls
to watch how they dress because it's
distracting to their teachers and it
makes their male relatives
uncomfortable. No, no, we don't need to
deal with any of that because the
problem is simply
Satanists. This kind of distancing
sensationalism really reached its peak
with the conspiracy theory known as
Frazzled Drip. And if you haven't heard
of this, I'm so excited that I get to be
the one to tell you. Frazzled or
frazzled. is the name of a fogloric file
supposedly discovered on the laptop of
former US Representative Anthony Weiner,
which according to internet rumor
contains a snuff film so depraved it
made hardened NYPD detectives cry like
little [ __ ] before committing
suicide. The video supposedly shows
Hillary Clinton and her staffer Huma
Abdine enacting a satanic ritual
sacrifice in which they
They rip a little girl's face off of her
face and take turns wearing the face as
a mask while committing sadistic sex
acts and drinking the adrenalized blood
of this now faceless
child. Okay. And what happens next? Does
Squidward unal alive himself? Is a clown
going to murder me in the bath if I
don't share this with my top eight
MySpace friends by midnight? Chad, I
need you to understand that this
lowquality creepy pasta is not some
obscure piece of fringe QAnon lore. The
Frazzled rumor emerged in 2018, but to
this day, people post about it on
conspiracy Twitter and conspiracy Reddit
on like a weekly basis. There's a whole
extended lore about how wearing a
child's face as a mask is a common
adrenochrome harvesting method, and that
the media is full of symbolism alluding
to the practice. For example, Lady
Gaga's outfit at the 2009 VMAs. Guys, if
you see a red lace dress and your first
thought is that looks like a child who's
been skinned alive, the problem is
within you. See also the Basot painting
on a hoodie worn by Ellen DeGeneres and
Jay-Z and Wilson the volleyball from the
movie Castaway. This last example is
cited by conspiracists as evidence that
beloved actor Tom Hanks is in fact a
sodomistic pedor who routinely gluts
himself on the adrenochrome rich blood
of slaughtered children. So anyone who's
even slightly tethered to reality can
tell this isn't true. But I, as a close
personal friend of Hillary, am in a
unique position to prove it isn't true
because I have seen the real Frazzle
Drip. I have it right here on
VHS. Let's watch it now.
Place the mask into position as before
and get ready for a real treat. The
first time you position the mask,
sometimes I get the labels on want to
use to help you align it properly. When
positioning the mask, the four facial
contact areas on the mask, it's probably
this
one. Oh, yeah. This is
it. Mother of
darkness, embrace me.
[Music]
Take a [ __ ] sip,
babes. I love the smell of adrenochrome
in the morning.
Satanis, hail
mool. The arm came off. Hillary, no. I
can't believe the World Economic Forum
is paying me to do this. So, at a
certain point, and we have reached that
point, conspiracy theory becomes too
dignified a term for what is essentially
a perverted form of morbid
entertainment. I have a good eye for
perversion because I am a pervert. I
know how perverts think. So you can
trust me when I say conspiracists are
perverts. People who are not perverts do
not spend this much time thinking about
debauched satanic sex crimes. Now
conspiracists will be like, "How dare
you? We are concerned citizens who are
saving children and doing our own
research." No, you're not. No, you're
not. Posting about celebrity face
harvesting rituals is not research and
it's not saving children. and I'm simply
not going to allow you to get away with
pretending that it is. I think this
whole moral crusade is largely an excuse
for you to spend a lot of time talking
and thinking about Saudian sexual
depravity. There's an element of lust in
every witch hunt. In the 1486 witch
hunting manual Malayas Malifakarum,
there's a kind of horny obsession with
women [ __ ] demons. Incubus, a male
demonic force that populates with human
females. Witch trials often involved the
invasive inspection of women's bodies
for so-called witches marks. There's a
scene in the law enforcement guide to
satanic cults
where you just have to see it to believe
it. You'll note on our model that
there's often times a cut that goes from
behind the ear all the way down to the
throat. Another area that's obvious in
these kinds of ritualistic carvings
would be the pentagram or the inverted
pentagram on the right and the left side
of the upper chest. It is our sacred
obligation to uproot the sexual deviency
that is corrupting our children and
putrifying our communities. Now look
over here at our bikini model whose per
nubile body we're going to inspect for
marks of the devil. Another area we'll
want to note is the foot area. These are
not serious people. Richard Hoffadder
said that anti-atholicism has always
been the pornography of the Puritan.
Pornography. He was talking about awful
disclosures and those allegations about
fornicating nuns murdering babies. 19th
century conspiracists developed a quote
immense lore about libertine priests,
the confessional as an opportunity for
seduction, lentious convents and
monasteries. Today, satanic panics are
the pornography of the Puritan. Satan is
a symbol of temptation and whatever the
Puritan represses in himself he
attributes to the Satanist. Sex, drugs,
hedonism, violence, luxury, the eyes
wide shut style conspiracy of forbidden
temptations. Well, I've had a very
interesting look around. The philosopher
Sart noticed something similar in his
essay on anti-semitism. He says, "I knew
a Protestant in whom sexual desire took
the form of indignation." My god, that's
disgusting. Naked pics online. Where
where did he post those? The sight of
women in bathing suits aroused him to a
fury. He willingly encouraged that fury
and passed his time at swimming pools.
Look at that disgusting display. Yes,
sir. The anti-semite is like that. His
behavior reflects a curiosity fascinated
by evil. But above all, I think it
represents a basic
[Music]
sadism. So, what does that mean? What is
the sadism he's talking about? Well,
there's two types of sadism in a witch
hunt. Sadism one is the curiosity
fascinated by evil. This morbid pleasure
in denial that we take in going down the
rabbit hole of sick and twisted crimes
which we attribute to the witch. Such a
clever witch to twist the truth to cloud
the mind with unholy thoughts. Sadism
too is the pleasure of retribution
justice served. Burning the witch. I
think these same two types of sadism are
the reason police shows like Law and
Order SVU are so enjoyable. In the
criminal justice system, sexually based
offenses are considered especially
heinous. The framing of a police
procedural provides a legitimate context
that gives us permission to indulge
whatever morbid curiosity we may have
about especially heinous sexually based
offenses. That's sadism one. And then
because those sexually based offenses
are so especially heinous, we feel a
sense of satisfaction when those hero
cops bring down the hammer of the law on
whatever creeper pervert of the weak.
Retribution justice served. That's
sadism, too. I'll tell you what I think,
pervert. You can't hide from me behind
your fancy
education. I smell you. I think this
same dynamic explains a type of cultural
fixation on pedophilia. I mean, it's
right there in the name of the show.
It's called To Catch a Predator, not To
Protect a Child. There are no children
on that show. In To Catch a Predator,
the media and the cops collaborate to
essentially create a crime for the
purpose of televising the punishment.
It's entramentainment. And I'm not
asking anyone to feel sorry for the
predators they catch. I'm just trying to
keep it real about the reason that this
show exists. A lot of people obsess over
real or imagined crimes against
children, not out of sincere concern for
victims. Put our ass back in the cabin,
but simply because crimes against
children provide a really good
justification for retributive violence.
It's why wararmongering politicians
often say the enemy is killing babies
because it's a crime that cries out for
revenge that warrants unlimited
retaliation. In 2017, the first ever Q
drop claimed that Hillary Clinton had
been arrested and was being extradated.
So from day one, QAnon was a retributive
fantasy that appealed to Trump
supporters who were beginning to wonder
when the Donald was planning to fulfill
his campaign promise to lock her up. And
from there, it escalated into this idea
of the storm, the public mass executions
of politicians aligned with the Cabal.
So that's another function of the
satanic ritual abuse conspiracy. It
sanctions violence and it sanctifies
violence. It makes violence sacred
because violence against evil is good.
And what could be more evil than satanic
pedophiles who murder children and wear
their faces like a mask. So like to
catch a predator, Qanon was in many ways
a bunch of people standing around a
gallows looking for a criminal to hang.
Scapegoating, the need to blame and
punish someone, is where the three
principles of conspiracism come
together. Intentionalism, because
punishment needs a criminal. Dualism,
because if the criminals are purely
evil, we can rest assured our violence
against them is purely righteous. And
symbolism, because we need a method to
discover criminals and reveal their
purely evil nature. This is how a
cultist talk to each other. This here is
a psilocybin mushroom. So satanic
rituals are proof both of guilt and of
deliberate allegiance to the devil.
Where does this desire for retaliation
come from? Why does scapegoating happen?
Well, one, it can be a response to an
unintended disaster like COVID 19 where
conspiracists blamed Bill Gates or the
World Health Organization or the
Chinese. Two, it can be a response to an
actual crime like 9/11, a crime against
the American people. We couldn't
retaliate against the hijackers
obviously, but from the moment the
second plane hit the south tower, it was
collectively decided we were going to
retaliate against someone and Iraq and
Afghanistan became the surrogate
victims. We will make no distinction
between the terrorists who committed
these acts and those who harbor them.
Three, scapegoating can be an act of
projective guilt where our own guilt or
feeling of guilt is either forgiven or
repressed by transferring guilt to the
scapegoat. This is actually closest to
the origin of the concept of
scapegoating in Leviticus where on the
day of atonement, the high priest lays
his hands on the head of a goat and
confesses the sins of the Israelites. He
then sends the goat out into the desert
symbolically transferring the sins away
from the community. Conspiracists are
usually not as self-aware about this as
the Israelites. A month before Edgar
Madison Welch, the Pizzagate shooter,
barged into Comet Ping Pong with an
AR-15, he'd severely injured a
13-year-old pedestrian in a car
accident. On his drive to DC, he
recorded a message to his own kids about
his duty to protect children. Protect
people who can't protect themselves.
The8s satanic panic began when Michelle
Smith came to her psychiatrist, Dr.
Pazdar, with severe and persistent grief
she was experiencing over a recent
miscarriage. And it was only after Dr.
Pazer encouraged her to free associate
that she began recovering memories of
satanic ritual baby killing. Witches
chant and babies burn. Mustn't talk. It
will be my turn.
The 9/11 truth movement began before the
towers even fell and attracted a variety
of people for a variety of reasons, but
it didn't peak until 2006, around the
time American public opinion turned
against the war in Iraq. There were no
weapons of mass destruction. A sectarian
civil war had broken out with no end in
sight, and photos had been leaked of
American soldiers running a torture
prison at Abu Grae. So, it was around
2006 that Americans began to tell the
story of that war in the way we tell it
still. The Bush administration lied
about weapons of mass destruction and
tricked us all into going to war. That's
not entirely false, but it's not the
whole truth either. Weapons of mass
destruction were the pretext given, but
the evidence they provided was not very
convincing. The UN Security Council
didn't buy it. France, in particular,
didn't buy it and was very opposed to
the war. And Americans spent the next
several years calling the French cheese
eating surrender monkeys. I believe that
was the phrase. And renaming French
fries freedom fries. French's Mustard
had to release a statement disavowing
any association with the French
Republic. The only thing French about
French's Mustard is the name. Yeah, we
can tell. So that's how popular
Operation Iraqi Freedom was with
Americans in 2003 when 72% of Americans
supported the invasion and President
Bush's approval rating went up 13
points. I think at that particular
moment, Americans would have been
willing to go to war with almost any
Middle Eastern country on almost any
pretext. Some say this country's just
out of looking for a fight. after 911.
Man, I'd have to say that's right. Have
you I was a teenager at the time, but
I'll never forget the things I heard
adults openly saying on a regular basis.
Turn the Middle East to glass. It's too
bad we didn't win the crusades. Who the
[ __ ] is we? Christendom. My point is
that the Bush administration didn't sell
us anything we didn't want to buy. And
it took a few years for buyer's remorse
to set in. Only then did we need a
scapegoat on whom to pin our guilt for
the war. And we knew emotionally that
displaced revenge for 9/11, aka the war
on terror, was the deeper motivation. So
blaming Bush for lying about WMDs was
not enough. We needed 9/11 to have been
a trick as well. Despite what
conspiracists said, the real truth we
couldn't handle was not that the
Illuminati made us go to war, but that
they didn't. that no one made us do
anything.
[Music]
Part five. It's a big club and you ain't
in it. Okay. So, you know how a lot of
comedians when they're 10 years past
their peak, they stop telling jokes and
instead just get up on stage and do
political rants at the audience? Well,
every comic who does that wishes he was
George Carlin, a comedian who died in
2006 and who towards the end did some
specials with a lot of old man ranting.
The politicians are put there to give
you the idea that you have freedom of
choice. You don't. You have owners. They
own you. In one of Carllin's famous old
man rants, he talks about how America is
owned by wealthy business interests.
This bit culminates in the phrase, "It's
a big club and you ain't in it." That
line, "It's a big club and you ain't in
it," has become a popular conspiracist
slogan. You see it every day in online
conspiracy spaces. It captures
conspiracists core feeling of exclusion,
the feeling of being an outsider to
political power, speculating frantically
about what the insiders are up to. It's
interesting that conspiracists like this
line so much because George Carlin was
not a conspiracist. On a political talk
show, he name dropped Noom Chsky and
Howard Zinn, both thinkers I'd consider
reasonable leftists. Howard Zinn and Nam
Chsy, those people aren't on TV because
they have they have intellects and
they're dissenters. On another talk
show, Carlin was accused of being a
conspiracy theorist and he responded,
"You don't need a formal conspiracy when
interests converge." That is not
conspiracist talk. But conspiracists
claim Carlin as one of their own because
he communicates in populist language and
populism is inherently ambiguous. It's
always open to conspiracist
interpretation. Let's define populism as
the general idea that we, the common
people, are in opposition to some they,
the establishment elite. This is
extremely vague. And that's the problem.
Populism can be leftist. It can be
fascist. It can be liberal, centrist,
communist. Most political ideologies
today identify in some way with the
people in opposition to elites. It's why
a lot of American politicians put on
this folksy charade. You know what I'm
talking about. I grew up in a small
town. I work in a farm factory. I piss
in a bucket. I grew up castrating hogs
on an Iowa farm. Just ask the single mom
from Swing State who sits around the
kitchen table every night castrating
hogs or whatever it is you people do.
Are you a racist? Do you hate Mexicans?
I mean, I guess it works or they
wouldn't do it. Everyone wants to brand
themselves as
anti-establishment. The problem though
is anti-establishment is not in and of
itself an actual political agenda as any
successful revolutionary will tell you
because what happens after the
revolution. You have to create a new
establishment and then all your
anti-establishment rhetoric gets a
little awkward. It's a problem Mao
solved with the ingeniously Mchavelian
idea of a second revolution. Now, if you
don't know what kind of establishment
you want and don't have a realistic plan
for how to get it, well, then you're
just a complainer like George Carlin,
who was influenced by leftist but whose
politics was basically defeist. It will
never ever ever be fixed. It's never
going to get any better. Don't look for
it. Be happy with what you got. Don't
vote. Don't revolt. Don't expect things
to get better. The system's rigged. Just
sit back and laugh. And I get that. I'm
something of a professional complainer
myself. But the problem is, while we are
sitting back and laughing, people with
an agenda are getting things done. A
populist agenda is defined by where the
line is drawn between us and them. Who
are the people and who are the elites?
What is the big club that you ain't in?
And this is a matter of life and death,
so you better get this right. Populism
escalates into violence when tensions in
society reach a breaking point. Always a
risk in a culture lacking an established
ritual of sending a sin-laden goat out
into the desert once a year. Now, I'm a
liberal social democrat. I'd prefer to
improve society through democratic
reforms, but I'm aware my libk opinions
are not popular at the moment because
the right doesn't want reform. They want
to punish minorities and the left
doesn't want to vote. I was going to say
they want to smash, but they don't even
want to do that. They want to theorize
the inevitability of smashing, as
they've been doing for almost two
centuries now. So, one way or another,
the people are out for blood. The
question is, whose blood's it going to
be this time? I'm sure CEOs are a little
nervous right now, but probably not that
nervous. There's reliable ways to escape
the guillotine. Socialism always has to
compete with nationalism to channel
populist resentment. And socialism has a
critical weakness, which is that it's
just a little too intellectual.
Socialists try to create class
consciousness. That is, they tried to
build a workingclass we opposed to a
capitalist they. Marxist theory is not
conspiracist because the line between
workingclass and capitalist is defined
by an economic relation, not by
inclusion or exclusion from a
conspiracy. But that's a subtle
distinction that's hard to communicate
to normal people. And if you use weird
jargon like bgeoa and dialectic, you
sound like a creepy ideologue. So
popular socialists like Bernie Sanders
or sort of George Carlin don't say those
words. They say the 1%. They say it's a
big club and you ain't in it. That
language emotionally resonates with
people, but the subtlety is lost in
translation. Most people find
conspiracism more intuitive than
dialectical
materialism. Lord have mercy. Just
explain to Joe Rogan that it's simply a
non idealist in version of Hegelianism.
How difficult is that? For
conspiracists, the belief in a they
creates a wei. The line between us and
them is not based on class. It's based
on the conspiracy. They, the insiders,
are in on it. We, the outsiders, are
not. Conspiracist Gary Allen says,
"Unless you are an insider, you are a
victim. Whether you are a
multi-millionaire or a popper, you have
an enormous amount at stake." So
conspiracism potentially unites everyone
from billionaires to the unemployed in a
single we against the cabal, the deep
state, the globalists, the international
bankers, the radical left, the
reptilians. Just pick a convenient
scapegoat. Who cares, right? It's
conspiracism. Facts don't matter. This
makes conspiracism a billionaire's best
friend. At least a gentile billionaire.
It's how real estate mogul Donald Trump
and world's richest tech oligarch Elon
Musk were able to convince the people
that they, like us, are somehow
outsiders to the establishment elite.
Because when they say the elite, they
mean the woke elite, the DEI elite. They
mean minorities. For nationalists like
Trump, conspiracism is not just useful,
it's essential. Nationalism constructs a
native, ethnic, or racial we opposed to
a foreign, invasive, or degenerate they.
The populist version of nationalism,
national socialism, if you will, is the
idea that the native, ethnic, or racial
common people are opposed by a foreign,
invasive, or degenerate elite. And in a
country that's not literally ruled by a
foreign colonial power, the only way to
support that idea is with conspiracy
theories. So, now is probably the time
to unpin the anti-semitism discussion
that I've been pinning this whole video.
I put it off to avoid a comment section
overly choked with claims that
anti-semite is a slur designed to
silence truth seekers. Another favorite
conspiracist slogan goes, "To learn who
rules over you, simply find out who you
are not allowed to criticize."
BTS fans in Jewish Space Lasers. Mike
Rothschild, no relation to the wealthy
banking family, but you know, good luck
explaining that to the There are no
coincidences brigade. Mike Rothschild
says, quote, "Almost all conspiracy
theories are rooted in anti-semitism,
and almost all anti-semitism is rooted
in conspiracy theories." For research on
this video, I made an alt account on
x.com and even I was surprised by just
how fast the app pipelined me straight
to Hitler. And when I say Hitler, I
don't mean Hitler as matonomy for
bigotry in general. I mean Adolf Hitler,
Reich Chancellor of Germany from 1933
until the bullet hit his brain. Hitler
came to power and within 6 years,
Germany became the wealthiest economy in
the world. How did this happen? and
brother Joshua. Don't even trip. I got
you. Hitler implemented two laws to make
this happen. I could tell you about him
personally, but I'd rather have a Jewish
rabbi prove my point. If you think about
it, doesn't disagreeing with the pro-
Hitler rabbi make you the real
anti-Semite. Andrew Tate finally said,
"The Matrix is the Jews thread." Did you
know Kim Jong-un and his family are
Jewish? Oh, look. Passionate graphic
designer Dylan Lewis Monroe made a
sharable social media friendly summary
of the protocols of the Elders of Zion.
Convenient. These are some of the less
offensive posts. I can't even show you
most of it. While I was working on this
video, I went to a European war museum
that had a bunch of historic Nazi
propaganda. And honestly, some of the
stuff I was seeing on Twitter was
actually worse. If you don't believe me,
I did screenshot evidence. There is so
much Nazi propaganda on my phone. Yeah,
it's mostly Nazi propaganda. Oh, that
was a nice dinner. Conspiracists are
constantly bickering among themselves
about the answer to the question, who is
they? with many preferring elaborate
euphemisms like globalists, elitists,
frankists, sabotans, communists, deep
state, Zionists, oligarchists,
Rothschild bankers. And if you call out
the euphemisms, the conspiracist says,
"Wow, did you just assume I was talking
about all Jews when I said the deep
state Rothschild Frankists?" Doesn't
that make you the real anti-semite? But
now that hate speech restrictions are
being lifted on many platforms, a lot of
them have started encouraging each other
to just say Jews. Now, it has to be said
that a lot of these people are using
Israel's crimes against Palestine as a
pretext, and those crimes are real, and
the Trump administration really is
citing anti-semitism to justify
crackdowns on protests and universities.
But it certainly doesn't help that
conspiracists are exploiting the
situation to promote Hitilarian Jew
hatred. So, why is conspiracism a funnel
that leads to Hitler? Well, a bunch of
reasons. One, Hitler was a conspiracy
theorist. People don't usually
categorize him that way, but he was. My
struggle is full of ramblings about how
like the Jews control the Freemasons and
they're going to make us all speak
aspirto. I assume conspiracists must
find this relatable. Just kidding. They
don't read. Kids these days can't even
be bothered to read mine comp. Sad. Two,
conspiracism is about scapegoating. And
in Western culture, Jews are a
traditional scapegoat. The Jews stole
this from you. Israel took this from us.
No, our beautiful dead wife, he was
taken by Israel. Okasan, the Jews are to
blame for my attraction to
minors. Now that is how you escape a
goat. Three, Jews are associated with a
bunch of other things conspiracists are
obsessed with, like Hollywood and
finance. Nationalist conspiracism needs
to identify an out group as the elite.
And it's especially the association with
money that makes Jews the favorite
target because the world revolves around
money and money is mysterious. Who
controls the money? The association
between Jews and finance began in
medieval Europe where Jews were
second-ass citizens prohibited from
practicing most trades. One exception
was money lending which Christians
couldn't practice because the church
condemned userie. So monarchs and nobles
would hire a so-called court Jew to
handle their finances. Most famously
Meer Amchel Rothschilds who rose from a
Jewish ghetto in Frankfurt and whose
five sons started businesses across
Europe creating a banking dynasty that
in the 19th century made the Rothschilds
the richest private family in the world.
So there is some grain of truth here,
but as usual it does not correspond to
the things conspiracists are saying. The
Rothschilds do not control every
country's central bank. They do not own
the government and media. They have
nowhere near the influence of today's
top oligarchs. And no, they do not eat
babies. A lot of people feel that
there's something occult and unnatural
about finance itself. It's making money
from money, which seems like evil
alchemy, black magic. And this should
not be conflated with reasonable
criticism of finance capitalism. The
conspiracist accusation is of witchery
and that the Rothschilds intentionally
sunk the Titanic to create the Federal
Reserve in a secret meeting on Jackal
Island, which may or may not have been
attended by Satan himself, and so on.
There's a saying that anti-semitism is
the socialism of fools. It appeals to
people who sense that something is wrong
with our economy, that money is somehow
corrupting politics in media, but they
don't know enough about any of those
things to criticize it intelligently.
Nationalists object to the elite, not
just as a power over us, but as a
foreign power over us. Their complaint
is that the elite are not people like
us. Socialist intellectuals tend to be
very optimistic about transcending gut
level blood and soil nationalism by
redirecting attention to intellectual
class analysis. But anti-semitism is the
socialism of fools and there's a lot of
fools. Leftism unfortunately does not
inoculate people against foolishness.
Socialist revolutions are always at risk
of turning nationalist. Stalin diverged
from Marx, declaring socialism in one
country. And despite his role in
defeating Hitler, he eventually went on
to carry out his own little purge of
rootless cosmopolitans. That is Jews.
Fools of the world unite. In a video I
made years ago about Hold
on, capitalism. I suggested that David
Ike's reptilians could be ironically
appropriated as a metaphor for the
ruling class, like in the movie They
Live. Some people criticize this as
anti-Semitic. And I've come to basically
agree with that criticism. To be clear,
David Ike believes in literal
extraterrestrial reptilians. It's not
intended as a metaphor, though Ike does
say anti-Semitic stuff all the time. I
mean, he says Hitler was a Rothschild.
See appendix 2. Hitler was a Rothschild.
But reptilian overlords as a metaphor
imply elites who are alien, who are
outsiders, and that makes the metaphor
inherently suggestive of conspiracist
bigotry. Anti-semitism is the archetype
of this kind of bigotry. Though Jews are
by no means the only targets, LGBT
people are likewise often accused of
wielding a powerful agenda due to the
disproportionate prevalence of gay
people in arts and entertainment. Again,
grain of truth, but it's due largely to
discrimination in most other industries
and not due to a conspiracy.
Conspiracists invoke queercoded villain
in media like the capital dandies in the
Hunger Games to insinuate that the
establishment elites are gay. This has
nothing to do with any kind of Marxist
intellectualizing about material
conditions. Populist bigots don't want
equality. They want to be ruled by
people they identify with, by people
like them. Hatred of an outsider unites
people across economic classes in the
shared community of a lynch mob. So
bigotry in general is useful to
politicians, but conspiracist bigotry is
particularly useful because it empowers
them to continue railing against the
establishment elite, the source of all
our problems, even after they've
ascended to the throne. Richard Nixon,
when he was literally the president, was
endlessly conspiracist about the liberal
establishment. The press is the enemy.
The establishment is the enemy. The
professors are the enemy. It's ironic
considering Nixon perpetrated the most
famous real conspiracy in American
history, but I actually don't think
that's an accident. I think conspiracist
politicians are actually more likely to
perpetrate actual conspiracies because
their belief in a conspiracy or their
followers belief in a conspiracy
justifies plotting a counter conspiracy.
Donald Trump really did conspire to
overturn the results of the 2020
election. Stop the steel was a counter
conspiracy which people supported on the
basis of a false conspiracy theory that
Biden stole the election. And now with
Trump in power once again, do we expect
the right to turn on him when things do
not go well? No, of course not. They'll
keep digging into further layers of the
deep state, looking for new scapegoats
and new conspiracies to externalize the
blame. That is until this wave of
fascism crashes and recedes and then
suddenly they'll deny they ever
supported Trump. Or they'll claim the
Illuminati made them do it. That Trump
was a Roth's child. No responsibility
will be taken. Nothing will be learned.
You know, I've often thought that if you
simply translated Hitler's speeches into
English and updated a few details that
Americans would completely buy it. A few
months ago, that thought was proven
right. Hitler's AI translated speeches
go viral on Tik Tok with one video
topping 1 million views in troubling
trend. Is this what you thought the
future would be? Using AI to bring
Hitler back? I'm sure they're being
normal about this over on the conspiracy
subreddit. Let's take a look. Hitler may
not have been what we've been told he
was. Here we go. This is a AI translated
speech by Hitler where I expected to
hear him babble incoherence, but he was
actually spoton about a lot of issues.
He calls out the elite banking class,
the stock market, the elucory two-party
system, the globalists, an outsider
minority forming a nation within a
nation, hyperinflation, etc. blamed the
Jews for everything. The poster then
pastes what appears to be a chat GPT
summary of conspiracy theories Hitler
believed and then declares promoting
communist ideals, degenerate ideals,
liberal ideals about sexuality and
gender roles, undermining Christianity.
Guys, it's the same [ __ ] happening
today. The post concludes by pointing
out that Nazis burned books about
transsexualism and therefore that Hitler
was, dare I say it, based I think we all
owe Hitler an
[Music]
apology, guys. I started out this video
trying to be nice, but this post has
spent the last of my patience. It's just
so
stupid. How can you be this stupid? I'm
not asking you to be an intellectual.
I'm not asking you to write a thesis on
[ __ ] Vickenstein. I'm asking you to
be 10% smarter than the absolute dumbest
it is possible for a human to be. It
boggles my mind how susceptible to
propaganda you are. It's not like
someone tricked you by giving you a
transcript without telling you who wrote
it. They told you it was Hitler. And
when you agreed with it anyway, did you
question your own
judgment? No.
The first thought through that infinite
decimally tiny brain of yours was that
the mainstream media has lied to us
about
Hitler. There's a reason they only let
us see him speaking
German. I honestly can't believe it. I
cannot believe how god damn dumb you
are. It is actually astounding.
Mom needs a
Xanax. Part six. I can't think of a
section for this title. Doctor, I'm too
depressed. This isn't very low
vibrational crochet I'm doing here. What
am I even making? Like a pot holder for
deformed pots. I am weaving a web of
truth. Okay, I don't want to hear any
crap about it in the comments. So, I
suspect the main criticism of this video
from conspiracists will be that I didn't
debunk anything. And that's true. My
goal has been to analyze a way of
thinking, not to, you know, litigate the
evidence of JFK Jr. living in secret
tunnels beneath Denver International
Airport. I don't know what he's doing
down there, and I'm not interested in
finding out. The problem with debunking
is it's not an efficient use of time.
Some nerd online came up with an idea
called Brandolini's law. The amount of
energy needed to refute [ __ ] is an
order of magnitude bigger than that
needed to produce it. Conspiracists can
invent a hundred conspiracies in the
time it takes to debunk one. And even
then, they'll invent a conspiracy to
explain the lack of evidence for the one
you just debunked. Conspiracism is a
parody of critical thinking that
empowers people to believe whatever they
want to believe and to dismiss anything
challenging or inconvenient. Has a
disaster happened that's awkward for
your politics? Just say it was a hoax.
Are other conspiracists inciting
violence? Just say it's controlled
opposition. To a conspiracist
politician, every lost election is a
rigged election. And there's usually a
very selective and politically
convenient understanding of what even
counts as a conspiracy. Like
conspiracists who think survivors of
school shootings advocating firearms
regulation are a conspiracy. But the
billiondoll industry lobbying to prevent
that regulation, that's fine. That's not
a conspiracy. If you spend long enough
immersed in this kind of discourse, you
start to lose your grip on the concept
of truth. After months of conspiracy
research, I feel a withered sense of
reality, even as a detached and hostile
observer. So, what do we do with these
people? Can they be reasoned with at
all? The answer is usually no. And
that's scary because democracy depends
on us being able to deliberate. When
people can't communicate, conflicts
escalate into violence. But there's also
a personal cost to this. The subreddit
QAnon Casualties has thousands of posts
from people whose families and
relationships have been torn apart by
one person's obsessive conspiracism.
People talk about losing someone to
this. The way we talk about drug
addiction. It's like conspiracy research
completely takes over some people's
lives. It becomes the only thing they
care about, the only thing they talk
about, and it changes their personality.
And I'm sure people who know someone
like that will ask, "How can I save my
loved one?" And the only honest answer I
can give is, "I don't know." This is not
a video on how to blue pill your crazy
uncle. I think it's like addiction. You
can't force someone to change if they
don't want to change. You just can't
force feed someone blue pills. That's
what we have 5G towers for. But to even
have a chance of getting people out, we
should at least understand what gets
them in. And I do have a few final
thoughts about that. Why do some people
get addicted to conspiracy theories? I
think conspiracism must fulfill some
deep psychological needs. Need one is
relief from fear. I'm sorry, we're in
another list within a list. To
understand the structure of this video,
please consult this diagram. Fear is an
inherent part of politics. There's no
limit to how horrible humans can be to
each other, and it's very scary. I
personally am terrified of politics at
the moment, so I get it. But why does
conspiracism soothe fear? It seems
counterintuitive. The idea that the
world is controlled by an evil
cryptoaristocracy doesn't sound very
soothing. Like, are these people
masochists? Do they unconsciously want
to be dominated by the Illuminati? Now
that I say it out loud, it actually does
sound kind of hot. Okay, I get it.
Michael Barkland says, "The conspiracy
theorist's view is both frightening and
reassuring." Reassuring because it
promises a world that is meaningful
rather than arbitrary. So even if it's
scary to think the world is controlled
by Satanists, it's also a relief because
it means that everything happens for a
reason. It's like religion in that way.
Many people find it comforting to
imagine that God has a plan for us, even
if that plan involves earthquakes and
tsunamis. The Lord works in mysterious
ways. I personally do not find this
comforting at all. I do not understand
the archetypal appeal of the punishing
father. You know, it's like daddy
arrived and he's taken his belt off. But
so many people seem to be into it. So,
it's a thing. There has to be a point at
which dad comes home.
Yeah, that's
right. And he's
pissed. Dad is pissed. Need two is
inflated self-esteem. There's something
inherently grandiose about the whole
conspiracist persona. Conspiracy
researchers or investigators claim to
have privileged access to secret
knowledge thanks to their bravely
defiant Galileoike willingness to ask
dangerous questions the brainwashed
sheeple dare not entertain. It's such a
teenage mindset, right? I remember
thinking this way when I was 16. I alone
question the system. Everyone else is a
programmed sheep who does as they're
told. But I am burdened with an inner
darkness that lets me see the truth.
That high school is a prison.
Conspiracists take this narcissism even
further. It's not enough for them to be
Socrates and Sherlock Holmes. They also
have to be Jesus Christ, some kind of
persecuted murderer heroically fighting
the forces of evil and the information
war. It's like Don Kote, the book we all
pretend to have read about an aging
noble who reads chivalrich fantasy
novels all day and deludes himself into
thinking he's a knight. For
conspiracists, the persona of
investigator gives them a noble purpose.
It makes them important. But instead of
giants, they think windmills are
directed energy weapons. And instead of
chivalick fantasy, their literary model
is like the dystopian fiction we had to
read in high school. 1984, Brave New
World, Fahrenheit
451, you are here. Oh my god, how can
the richest man on Earth have this much
of a persecution complex? There's not
enough ketamine in the world to fix
this. Need three is revenge humiliation.
I've noticed a lot of professional
conspiracy theorists became what they
are after some experience of public
humiliation. David Ike was a BBC sports
presenter until his 1991 appearance on
the TV talk show Wogan, where he
announced to the British public that he
was the son of God and prophecied a
plague of tidal waves and earthquakes.
The press claim that you claim to be the
son of God. Mhm. Is that true? Yes. You
see, the thing is that you see it's
quite it's quite funny really. The
studio audience ridiculed him live on
air and afterward he says he quote
couldn't walk down any street in Britain
without being laughed at. It was a
nightmare. My children were devastated
because their dad was a figure of
ridicule. This got him wondering who
really was behind this vicious smear
campaign. And his answer to that
question was apparently reptilians. An
idea he promoted on a lecture tour of
North America where this sort of
behavior is appreciated. Where nations
of the world send all their maniacs.
Likewise, Naomi Wolf went from respected
liberal feminist to conspiracist co-host
of Steve Bannon's podcast and one of the
most deranged posters in the history of
X.com. No.
No. Naomi was never the best fact
checker, but her descent fully began
during a 2019 BBC radio interview about
her new book on 19th century persecution
of homosexuality when the host noticed
that a fundamental premise of her book
was based on a misunderstanding of legal
terms. Any author knows this is a
nightmare scenario, but Twitter was
gleefully mean about it because Twitter
is a gleefully mean place. Within a
year, Naomi had become a leading CO 19
conspiracy theorist. Antivax, anti-mask,
ranting about chemtrails and 5G towers.
It was like she was taking her revenge
on the concept of factuality itself.
What the heck is in our oxygen supply?
Candace Owens is a conservative pundit
whose latest obsession is claiming that
Judaism is controlled from within by a
secret sect called Frankists who
practice ritual murder and child abuse.
These pedophiles are in power. What we
are referring to is a religion that is
known as frankism which we came to the
limo religion. It is the preferred
religion of the elites. Okay? They
believe and they worship the devil. You
can't even say that this is like a
modern take on blood label because it's
literally just blood liel. Candace Owens
is a blood liel promoter. But Candace
once was a progressive. In high school,
she experienced racist threats from
classmates, influencing her to become a
critic of systemic racism until an
incident in 2016 when she launched
social autopsy.com, a platform that
would archive offensive social media
posts and connect them to posters names,
which would then be searchable by
employers. This did not go over well on
any part of the political spectrum. The
consensus was that she had created
essentially a doxing database and the
internet responded as the internet does
by doxing Candace. In other words, she
was cancelled and she blamed this on
progressives saying it became a
conservative overnight. You know, I
realized that liberals were actually the
racists, that liberals were actually the
trolls. And then Trump is on the screen
saying that the media is lying, that CNN
is fake. It all began to resonate with
me because I realized that everything he
was saying was true because I knew that
the media hired hitmen. Within a year,
she was denying the existence of
systemic racism and claiming that black
Americans problems stem from welfare,
handouts, broken families, you know, the
song and dance. So, it seems like Naomi
Wolf and Candace Owens feminism and
anti-racism were mostly based on
personal feelings of persecution. And
then the moment they felt personally
persecuted by progressives, they
switched teams and became a conservative
overnight. Conspiracism appeals to
people who feel humiliated because it
externalizes blame and casts you as the
hero fighting back. 2,000 years ago, had
a guy called Jesus sat here and said
these same things, you would still be
laughing. It's really, really funny that
we've not really moved on that much. Of
course, for everyday non-ceelebrity
conspiracists, the source of that
humiliation might be more subtle. It
could be a divorce, losing a job, or
just a feeling that your life didn't
turn out the way you wanted it to. You
miss being young and full of hope, and
you're like, "Who took that from me?
Remember what the Jews took from
you?" God. At the beginning of The
Matrix, Mr. Anderson's life sucks. He
lives in a dirty bachelor pad. He hates
his job. He's humiliated by his boss.
Either you choose to be at your desk on
time from this day forth, or you choose
to find yourself another job. But then
he takes the red pill and learns that
his job, his boss, his taxes, all of
that was just an evil simulation. A lot
of men in particular feel humiliated by
modernity itself. Like in Fight Club,
these middle-class men feel emasculated
by their white collar jobs. Cucked. And
conspiracy investigation can be a way to
reclaim heroic masculinity from the
comfort of your desk chair. And it is a
traditionally masculine activity, though
recently that's changed. A lot of women
get into conspiracism via alternative
health and wellness, often after
frustrating or humiliating experiences
with mainstream medicine, which can
still be quite misogynistic. A lot of
women got into QAnon because of its meto
adjacent themes of exposing powerful sex
criminals and the sort of heroic
femininity of saving children. Just as
conspiracism has always enabled cranks
to play the intellectual without real
learning, QAnon enabled women to care
for children without the difficult parts
of caring for children. It's child care
without the child. I understand the
appeal. My children are my subscribers.
Like and subscribe. Universal in
conspiracy discourse is a longing for
vindication. This sense of you will all
see, then you'll be sorry. The ultimate
conspiracist wishfulfillment fantasy is
the end of the movie National Treasure,
where conspiracist Frank Nicholas Cage
is no longer a disappointment to his
father. He's vindicated to all the
academics who mocked him. He's wildly
rich and Diane Krueger wants to [ __ ]
him. Yes, we all have our little
fantasies. All of this is deeply
pathetic, but I think it's important to
understand because it explains why it's
so difficult to reason people out of
conspiracism. You're not just asking
them to change their mind. You're asking
them to give up an identity that makes
them feel like they matter, and they're
not going to do that until they find
something else to fill the void. Need
four is the denial of privilege. Another
reason the left always loses. That's a
good way to start a section. A little
bit of optimism. Another reason the left
always loses is the left wants you to
check your privilege. And no one wants
to do that. We all participate in
systems of exploitation to some extent,
not because we're evil, but just out of
passive inertia. But acknowledging that
is emotionally difficult because it
makes you feel guilty. It makes your
persecuted martyr persona look
ridiculous and it burdens you with
obligations to other people. God forbid.
Conspiracists on the other hand always
assure you that you are at the bottom of
the pyramid. You are here. This
validates your pain and sense of
victimhood and it protects you from
having to consider that you may in some
way be involved in the oppression of
other people. Morpheus tells Neo, "The
matrix is everywhere. It is the world
that has been pulled over your eyes to
blind you from the truth." What
truth? That you are a slave. Neo, in a
way, it's the ultimate white person
fantasy that a wise black man tells you
that it's you who's really the slave.
Conspiracists don't think in terms of
systems. To them, oppression is always
an intentional act of evil. This makes
them amazingly oblivious to more diffuse
forms of power like the power of men
over women or the power of an empire
over its colonies. In other words,
conspiracists do not notice the clubs
that they are in. Now, if you point this
out, you'll be told that this is
identity politics, which is a tactic the
elites use to divide us. Okay? But those
divides are already there. you just
choose not to notice them except when
it's convenient and it blinds you to the
truth about the real reasons for
oppression and injustice. Most of us in
fact exist somewhere in the middle of
the pyramid. Most people watching this
video benefit to some extent from a very
unequal global distribution of power
built on the exploitation of other
people, other species, and the earth
itself. Conspiracists love their
livestock metaphors, always comparing we
the people to cattle and sheep. But how
do we the people treat literal sheep and
cattle? Not well. I noticed most
conspiracists are not vegan. And I'm not
being preachy here. I'm not vegan
either. Yes, I've seen all the sad vegan
documentaries and I agree. The way
animals are treated is horrible. But it
doesn't actually motivate me to stop
eating meat. Why? Well, I've been
introspecting about this and I think
it's because I am just not that good of
a person. Not that I'm satanic. I don't
slaughter animals for fun while chanting
the names of demons. At least not
anymore. I've listened and I'm learning.
But I am complacent and selfish. I
prioritize my own habits, comfort,
health, and pleasure. I don't have this
martyr impulse. I don't think this makes
me evil. I think it makes me morally
average. And when you take a vast global
economy built on centuries of
exploitation and fill it with morally
average primates who evolved to survive
in small groups with limited resources,
you really don't need a conspiracy to
explain the results. If you want to
understand the mindset of the elites,
look at yourself. Billionaires are not a
different species. They're just people,
often broken people with way too much
power. When you deny the humanity of the
oppressors, you also conceal the
potential oppressor in yourself and in
all people, even people you think of as
the good guys. We are all metaphorically
part reptile. So stop hunting for
witches and Satanists and pay more
attention to ordinary selfishness,
ignorance, complacency, fear, envy,
sadism, scapegoating, the psychology of
mobs, the drive for retribution. And pay
attention to how all of that interacts
with power. These are the real forces
behind human events, not secret schemes
of shadowy super villains. There is no
epic battle between good guys and bad
guys. There's humans and there's power
and that's it. Who really controls the
world? No one. There are no adults. It's
just us. There is no plan unless we make
one.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Necrilia.
[Music]